Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is, therestishistory.com. Get to Toronto's main venues like Budweiser Stage and the new Roger Stadium with Go Transit. Thanks to Go Transit's special online e-ticket fares, a $10 one-day weekend pass offers unlimited travel on any weekend day or holiday, anywhere along the Go network. And the weekday group passes offer the same weekday travel flexibility across the network, starting at $30 for two people and up to $60 for a group of five.
感谢您收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告内容、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区吗？请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。再次强调，网址是 therestishistory.com。搭乘 GO Transit 前往多伦多百威舞台（Budweiser Stage）和全新罗杰斯体育场（Roger Stadium）等主要场馆。得益于 GO Transit 推出的专属在线电子客票优惠，只需 10 加元的周末一日通票即可在任何周末或节假日享受无限次搭乘，适用范围涵盖整个 GO 交通网络。平日团队通票则可在整个网络中提供同样的平日出行灵活性，两人起售价格为 30 加元，五人团队票最高为 60 加元。
Buy your online Go pass ahead of the show at gotransit.com slash tickets. This episode is brought to you by Dazon. For the first time ever, the 32 best soccer clubs from across the world are coming together to decide who the undisputed champions of the world are in the FIFA Club World Cup. The world's best players,
请在演出开始前在 gotransit.com/tickets 网站购买您的在线 GO 通票。本集由 DAZN 赞助播出。世界足联俱乐部世界杯（FIFA Club World Cup）历史上首次汇聚了来自全球的 32 支顶尖足球俱乐部，共同争夺无可争议的世界冠军头衔。世界上最优秀的球员们，
Messi, Holland, Kane, and more are all taking part. And you can watch every match for free on DAZN starting on June 14th and running until July 13th. Sign up now at dazon.com slash FIFA. That's D-A-Z-N dot com slash FIFA. So Tom, we've got some absolutely thrilling news for our listeners down under, don't we? We do, Dominic, because of of course this autumn sees England going to Australia to lose the ashes, but they're not the only group of Englishmen who will be heading to Australia because we are going there in November and December this year.
梅西、哈兰德、凯恩等球星都将悉数登场。从 6 月 14 日到 7 月 13 日，您可以在 DAZN 上免费观看每一场比赛。现在就前往 dazn.com/FIFA 注册。网址是 D-A-Z-N 点 com 斜杠 FIFA。那么汤姆，对于我们在南半球的听众来说，我们有一个绝对振奋人心的好消息，对吧？确实如此，多米尼克，因为今年秋天英格兰当然要去澳大利亚输掉骨灰杯（The Ashes），但他们并不是唯一一拨前往澳大利亚的英国人，因为我们将在今年 11 月和 12 月前往那里。
So we will be playing five tests, we'll be doing five shows in front of our beloved Australian audience. So in late November, we will be doing two shows in Sydney, including one of the opera house and Dominic. I'm particularly excited about that second show. In fact, so excited that I've gone off and not only changed my clothes, but changed the house where I'm recording this. And that's because, um, this second, we've had to launch it due to popular demand. Our first show in Sydney has already almost sold out.
所以我们将进行五场测试赛，不，我们将在我们深爱的澳大利亚观众面前举办五场演出。因此，在 11 月下旬，我们将在悉尼举办两场演出，其中包括在悉尼歌剧院的那场，多米尼克。我对第二场演出感到格外兴奋。事实上，兴奋到我不仅换了衣服，还换了录制这期节目的房子。这是因为，呃，这第二场演出，我们是因为大众的热烈需求而不得不推出的。我们在悉尼的第一场演出已经几乎售罄了。
So please do be sure to grab your tickets before the second show sells out too. And we will also be doing shows in Melbourne. And then the beginning of December, we will be doing shows in Adelaide and in Brisbane. Tickets are on general sale now at therestishistory.com. So for your chance to see us on stage live in an Australian city near you, simply head to the restishistory.com to get your tickets today. I have never seen David so excited as he was before de Valera arrived.
所以请务必抓紧抢票，以免第二场演出也售罄。我们还将在墨尔本举办演出。然后从 12 月初开始，我们将在阿德莱德和布里斯班举办演出。目前门票正在 therestishistory.com 上全面热售。因此，如果您想在您附近的澳大利亚城市现场观看我们的舞台演出，只需前往 therestishistory.com 即可在今天购票。我从未见过大卫像德瓦莱拉到达之前那样兴奋。
He had a big map of the British Empire hung up on the wall in the cabinet room, with great blotches of red all over it. This was to impress de Valera. In fact, David says that the aim of these talks is to impress upon de Valera the greatness of the empire and to get him to recognize it, and the king. David said to de Valera, the British Empire is a sisterhood of nations, the greatest in the world. Look at this table. There sits Africa,
内阁会议室的墙上挂着一张巨大的大英帝国地图，上面布满了大片的红色。这是为了给德瓦莱拉留下深刻印象。事实上，大卫说，这些会谈的目的就是让德瓦莱拉感受到帝国的伟大，并让他承认帝国以及国王。大卫对德瓦莱拉说：“大英帝国是一个国家姊妹会，是世界上最伟大的。看看这张桌子。坐在那里的是非洲，
English and Burr. There sits Canada, French, Scotch and English. There sits Australia, representing many races, even Māoris. There sits India. There sit the representatives of England, Scotland and Wales. All we ask you to do is to take your place in this sisterhood of free nations. It is an invitation, Mr. de Valera. We invite you here." So that was the diary of Frances Stevenson, who was personal secretary to David Lloyd-George, the Prime Minister of Britain, and it's her entry for the 14th of July, 1921. And Dominic, you wanted me to read that in a Cockney accent, but Francis
英国人和布尔人。坐在那里的是加拿大，法国人、苏格兰人和英国人。坐在那里的是澳大利亚，代表着许多种族，甚至是毛利人。坐在那里的是印度。坐在那里的是英格兰、苏格兰和威尔士的代表。我们对你唯一的请求，就是在这个自由国家的姊妹会中占据你的一席之地。这是一个邀请，德瓦莱拉先生。我们邀请你来到这里。”这就是弗朗西斯·斯蒂芬森的日记，她是英国首相大卫·劳埃德·乔治的私人秘书，这是她 1921 年 7 月 14 日的日记条目。多米尼克，你曾希望我用伦敦东区口音来读这段话，但弗朗西斯
Stevenson went to school in Clapham and as someone who lives in Brixton, I know that everyone in Clapham speaks like that. So yet again, my mastery of accent comes to the rescue. Okay. Very good. And she is describing there the first meeting between the chief minister of the British empire and the self declared Swadisone president of the Irish Republic.
斯蒂芬森曾在克拉珀姆上学，作为一个住在布里克斯顿的人，我知道克拉珀姆的每个人说话都那样。所以，我对比特（口音）的精通又一次拯救了局面。好的。非常好。她当时在描述的，是大英帝国的首席大臣与自封的爱尔兰共和国斯瓦迪森（Swadhin）总统之间的首次会晤。
And what I can't help noticing there is that even though she's been to a very good school in Clapham, she seems to think that Maori's live in Australia. So what's going on there? Yes, I saw that. Also, there's Africa, English and Burr. Yeah, I saw there are other people in Africa, but no one remembers who they were. Yeah, it's nice to mention the Zulus.
而我不禁注意到的是，尽管她曾在克拉珀姆一所非常好的学校上学，但她似乎认为毛利人住在澳大利亚。所以这到底是怎么回事？是的，我也看到了。还有，那里有“非洲，英国人和布尔人”。是的，我看到非洲还有其他人，但没人记得他们是谁了。是的，顺便提一下祖鲁人还是挺不错的。
Yes. So this meeting between Lloyd George and De Valera, is it a success? I mean, does this go down well with De Valera, this rhetoric? It's not a tremendous success. And we'll come back to this meeting a little bit later. Lloyd George afterwards said to Frances Stevenson that De Valera was, and I quote, the man with the most limited vocabulary he'd ever met. So that's slightly ominous. Frances Stevenson, by the way, she wasn't just his personal secretary, Lloyd George. Oh no. This is David Lloyd George we're talking about.
是的。那么，劳埃德·乔治和德瓦莱拉之间的这次会面，它算成功吗？我的意思是，德瓦莱拉对这种言辞买账吗？这算不上是一次巨大的成功。我们稍后会再回到这次会面。劳埃德·乔治后来对弗朗西斯·斯蒂芬森说，德瓦莱拉是——我引用他的话——“他见过的词汇量最贫乏的人”。所以这听起来有点不妙。顺便说一句，弗朗西斯·斯蒂芬森可不仅仅是他的私人秘书，劳埃德·乔治的秘书。哦，不。我们谈论的可是大卫·劳埃德·乔治。
She had been his mistress for almost a decade and she ended up marrying him after his wife died. So that's classic David Lloyd George behaviour and there'll be a lot of him in this episode. And Dominic, generally, David Lloyd George you view as a very bad man. You've repeatedly gone record as saying you don't like him, but I can't help looking at this episode. There seems to be a sneaking degree of admiration for him. Well, we shall see.
她做他的情妇将近十年，最终在他妻子去世后嫁给了他。所以这绝对是典型的大卫·劳埃德·乔治式的行为，本期节目中会有很多关于他的内容。而且多米尼克，总的来说，你把大卫·劳埃德·乔治视为一个非常糟糕的人。你曾多次公开表示不喜欢他，但我忍不住审视这期节目。你对他似乎有一种暗暗的赞赏。嗯，我们拭目以待吧。
I've said he's a bad man, a morally bad man, but listeners to this podcast since the beginning will know that quite a lot of morally bad men score quite highly in my estimation. Yeah. So a bad man, but a good negotiator. Well, we will see. So Tom, we've returned, haven't we? From Ireland. We were
我说过他是一个坏人，一个道德上的坏人，但从一开始就收听这个播客的听众会知道，相当多的道德败坏的人在我的评价中得分还挺高。是的。所以，他是一个坏人，但却是个优秀的谈判专家。嗯，我们拭目以待。那么汤姆，我们回来了，对吧？从爱尔兰。我们在
in Ireland for the last three episodes with friend of the show Paul Rouse and we got to the summer of 1921 with Paul didn't we? So we've been through two and a half years of guerrilla warfare and the British and the Irish have agreed a truce but excitingly the real drama is only just beginning because this episode is about one of the most gripping intrigues in modern political history. It's about the deal that created two entities on the island of Ireland. So on the one hand, you have a Protestant dominated Northern Ireland, and you have a Catholic dominated Irish free state, which eventually becomes the Republic of Ireland. This episode also has a tremendous cast of characters.
爱尔兰度过了过去的三期节目，嘉宾是节目的老朋友保罗·劳斯，我们和保罗一起聊到了 1921 年的夏天，对吧？所以我们经历了两年半的游击战，英国人和爱尔兰人已经达成了一项休战协议，但令人兴奋的是，真正的戏剧性才刚刚开始，因为这一期节目讲的是现代政治史上最引人入胜的阴谋之一。它讲的是在爱尔兰岛上创造了两个实体的那桩交易。一方面，你有一个由新教徒主导的北爱尔兰，另一方面，你有一个由天主教徒主导的爱尔兰自由邦，它最终成为了爱尔兰共和国。这一集还拥有极其豪华的角色阵容。
Who's your favorite? I think my favorite is the guy who was Churchill's great friend, who's the swell, who likes oysters and champagne and got... Lord Birkenhead. Yeah, Dr. Crippen's mistress off, didn't he? Yeah, F.E. Smith. F.E.
你最喜欢谁？我想我最喜欢的是丘吉尔的莫逆之交，那个花花公子，喜欢生蚝和香槟，而且... 伯肯黑德勋爵。对，就是把克里彭医生（Dr. Crippen）的情妇弄走的那个，对吧？对，F·E·史密斯。F·E·
Smith, Dan Jackson's great hero. He's a tremendous man. Yeah, he'll play a big part. So this episode, you've got him, you've got De Valera, you've got Lloyd George, you've got Winston Churchill, you have Michael Collins, a galaxy of stars. It's very exciting. It's like an ITV, light entertainment program from the 1980s. But the guy who really dominates is not an Irishman or an Englishman.
史密斯，丹·杰克逊（Dan Jackson）的伟大的英雄。他是个了不起的人物。是的，他将扮演重要角色。所以在这集节目里，有他，有德瓦莱拉，有劳埃德·乔治，有温斯顿·丘吉尔，有迈克尔·柯林斯，群星璀璨。这非常令人兴奋。这就像是 20 世纪 80 年代的一档独立电视台（ITV）轻松娱乐节目。但真正占主导地位的人既不是爱尔兰人也不是英国人，
It's a Welshman. We don't have enough Welshman on the rest of history, so it's great to get them in. So this is really Lloyd George's story and he's one of the great characters in British history. So just to give people, especially our overseas listeners, a sense of him. He's from an evangelical family in North Wales. He did lose his faith, but he's very, very intensely shaped by this kind of intensely religious non-conformist background.
而是一个威尔士人。我们在《历史的余烬》中没有足够的威尔士人，所以能把他们请进来真是太好了。所以这实际上是劳埃德·乔治的故事，他是英国历史上最伟大的人物之一。为了让大家，特别是我们海外的听众，对他的生平有一个概念。他来自北威尔士的一个福音派家庭。他的确失去了信仰，但他深受这种浓厚的宗教非国教背景的塑造。
Also an interesting thing, he was brought up speaking Welsh, not English. And that's interesting, isn't it? Because he's dealing here with a lot of Irish negotiators who are all frantically trying to learn Irish, but have English as their native tongue. No, you're absolutely right, Tom. And he will often, he will slightly tease the Irish negotiators about this. And in fact, he'll speak in Welsh to one of his colleagues, as we'll discover, a great ally of his called Tom Jones.
还有一个有趣的事情，他是说威尔士语而不是英语长大的。这很有趣，不是吗？因为他在这里要应对许多爱尔兰谈判代表，这些人都在拼命学习爱尔兰语，但英语却是他们的母语。不，你说得完全对，汤姆。而且他经常会就这一点稍微取笑一下爱尔兰谈判代表。事实上，正如我们将要发现的，他会用威尔士语和他的一个同事交谈，那是他的一个伟大盟友，名叫汤姆·琼斯。
Which is magnificent, isn't it? Yeah. A Welsh character called Tom Jones. Yes, exactly. So Lloyd George, his Welshness is massively important to him. He joined the Liberal Party as a populist outsider. He always sort of sees himself as an anti-establishment figure, even when he's prime minister.
这太棒了，不是吗？是的。一个叫汤姆·琼斯的威尔士人。是的，绝对的。所以劳埃德·乔治，他的威尔士人身份对他至关重要。他作为一名民粹主义局外人加入了自由党。他总是把自己视为一个反建制人物，即使在他担任首相的时候也是如此。
And his career is a really extraordinary story. So he's a rhetorically brilliant, this sort of aggressive oratory. He becomes a progressive chancellor of the Exchequer under Herbert Henry Asquith, one of the architects of the welfare state. On the other hand, he's very corrupt. He's a massive womanizer and he is totally and utterly untrustworthy. So in 1916, he had stabbed Asquith, his former patron, in the back with Conservative support to become Prime Minister.
而他的职业生涯是一个非常非凡的故事。他有着出色的辞令天赋，这种充满攻击性的雄辩术。他在赫伯特·亨利·阿斯奎斯（Herbert Henry Asquith）手下成为了一名富有进取心的财政大臣，也是福利国家的奠基人之一。另一方面，他非常腐败。他是一个超级花花公子，而且完全不可信。因此在 1916 年，他在保守党的支持下，在背后捅了他以前的伯乐阿斯奎斯一刀，从而当上了首相。
And by 1921 he is the acknowledged master of British politics, he's leading a coalition which is totally dependent on the support of the Conservatives. So if he ever loses that, he is out. And so effectively this great radical, the godfather of the British welfare state, is now, I mean Lord Beaverbrook said he was a Prime Minister without a party. Effectively he's in danger of being engulfed by the Conservatives, his great ancestral enemies. Exactly, that's exactly right. It's a really unusual situation in British political history where you have somebody who is seen as so charismatic, so dominating that he almost has started to float free from
到了 1921 年，他已经公认是英国政治的掌舵人，他领导着一个完全依赖保守党支持的联合政府。因此，如果他失去了这种支持，他就会下台。所以实际上，这位伟大的激进派、英国福利的教父，现在——也就是比弗布鲁克勋爵（Lord Beaverbrook）所说的“一个没有政党的首相”。实际上，他面临着被保守党——他的祖传大敌——吞噬的危险。没错，完全正确。这是英国政治史上一个非常罕见的情况，你会有这样一个人，他被认为极具魅力、极具统治力，以至于他几乎开始摆脱
party politics and to lead this kind of national coalition government purely on the basis of his personality rather than you know policies or anything like that. And so what's his take on Ireland? Well two important points there. One, his non-conformist background means that he absolutely despises Catholicism. I hate a priest wherever I can find him, he once said to one of his Welsh friends. He has no time for potpourri at all. And does the fact that he's from a Celtic background mean that he's more sympathetic to Irish dreams of home rule?
政党政治的束缚，纯粹依靠个人魅力，而不是政策或诸如此类的东西，来领导这种全国性的联合政府。那么他怎么看待爱尔兰问题呢？这里有两点很重要。第一，他的非国教背景意味着他绝对鄙视天主教。“无论在哪里发现神甫，我都讨厌他，”他曾对一位威尔士朋友说。他根本容不下天主教教义。那么他出身于凯尔特人背景，是否意味着他更同情爱尔兰关于地方自治的梦想呢？
No, counter-intuitively the opposite. So because he's a Celt and because his Welshness is so important to him, he just thinks what's wrong with the Irish. You see, he thinks Welshness is perfectly reconcilable with the ideal of Britain and British unity in the United Kingdom. And if we, the Welsh, are happy with it, what's wrong with the Irish? Why are they so troublesome? Why are they so difficult? Of course, you know, lots of people listen to this podcast will say, they've had very different histories.
不，凭直觉来看恰恰相反。正因为他是一个凯尔特人，而且他的威尔士人身份对他如此重要，他只会想：爱尔兰人到底有什么毛病？你看，他认为威尔士人的身份与英国及联合王国的英国统一理想是完全可以调和的。既然我们威尔士人对此很满意，那爱尔兰人到底有什么毛病？为什么他们这么麻烦？为什么他们这么难搞？当然，你知道，听这个播客的很多人会说，他们有着非常不同的历史。
But for Lloyd George, there is always a sense that he doesn't perhaps have the slight embarrassment that some English people have with the Irish, you know, he just thinks, come on, crack on, knuckle down. What are you whinging about? Yeah. Which a lot of English people are less likely I think to do because they feel a bit embarrassed about the history, about the famine and all of that kind of stuff. Yeah.
但对劳埃德·乔治来说，他总觉得，他或许没有某些英国人在面对爱尔兰人时感到的那种轻微的尴尬。你知道，他只会想：得了吧，赶紧振作起来，好好干活。你们在抱怨什么呢？是的。而许多英国人则不太可能这么做，我想，因为他们对历史、对饥荒以及所有诸如此类的事情感到有些尴尬。是的。
Now another really important point, I think someone's overlooked in accounts of the treaty negotiations. Imagine if you were Lloyd George in early 1921, you're running the British Empire. The world looks like it's in total chaos. You've had revolution and civil war in Russia. You've got massive unemployment in Britain and indeed across Europe. You've got war in the Eastern Mediterranean between Greece and Turkey. You have anti-colonial uprisings in India and Egypt. And at home you're under massive pressure. Britain has come very close in 1921 to a general
现在还有一个非常重要的观点，我认为在对条约谈判的记述中被忽略了。想象一下，如果你是 1921 年初的劳埃德·乔治，你正在管理大英帝国。世界看起来一片混乱。俄罗斯发生了革命和内战。英国乃至整个欧洲都面临着大规模的失业。希腊和土耳其之间在地中海东部爆发了战争。印度和埃及爆发了反殖民起义。而在国内，你承受着巨大的压力。1921 年，英国差一点就爆发了总
strike. Within the Tory party, a lot of people are saying, come on, Lloyd George is really corrupt and horrible. Let's get rid of him. And two of your closest allies, Winston Churchill and this guy, Lord Birkenhead, who you like. So Lord Birkenhead is the Tory, but Winston Churchill at this point is still a liberal. Exactly. And these are two colossal, charismatic, dominating figures who are basically plotting openly
罢工。在托利党内部，许多人都在说：得了吧，劳埃德·乔治真的很腐败很可怕，让我们把他赶下台吧。而你的两个最亲密的盟友，温斯顿·丘吉尔和这个你挺喜欢的家伙——伯肯黑德勋爵。所以伯肯黑德勋爵是托利党人，但温斯顿·丘吉尔此时仍然是自由党人。正是如此。而这两个都是庞大、富有魅力、占主导地位的人物，他们基本上在公开密谋
against Lloyd George. So what he doesn't need is a massive embarrassment and a drain on his political capital and that's what he thinks Ireland is. He thinks it's yet another element of instability and I want to fix it. And he doesn't care how he fixes it but he has two red lines. Red line number one, he thinks any settlement must preserve the unity of the British Empire. Basically, the last thing we want to do is to encourage nationalists in Egypt and India. It's really interesting actually how Ireland for Lloyd George and for the British generally
反对劳埃德·乔治。因此，他最不需要的就是一次巨大的尴尬以及对他政治资本的消耗，而这正是他认为的爱尔兰问题。他认为这是又一个不稳定的因素，他想要解决它。他不在乎自己是如何解决它的，但他有两条红线。第一条红线：他认为任何解决方案都必须维护大英帝国的统一。基本上，我们最不想做的事情，就是鼓励埃及和印度的民族主义者。实际上这真的很有趣，劳埃德·乔治和英国人通常认为，爱尔兰
is not just an issue in and of itself. What they're really worried about is that it would be an inspiration to people in India and in Egypt. I mean what that suggests is that they are associating Ireland with the non-white colonial possessions. Do you think that's fair? No, I don't necessarily think that is fair. I think what they're doing is they want Ireland to become like one of the dominions, like
不仅仅是一个孤立的问题。他们真正担心的是，它会成为印度和埃及人民的灵感来源。我的意思是，这表明他们将爱尔兰与非白人殖民地联系在了一起。你觉得这公平吗？不，我不认为这一定公平。我认为他们这样做是希望爱尔兰成为像自治领（dominions）那样的存在，比如
Canada or Australia. That ends up effectively being their solution. What they don't want is to have any precedent for any country to break away completely. Because that will inspire people in what they see as their strategically vital possessions which are Egypt and India. So that's red line number one. Red line number two is purely domestic for Lloyd George and that is any settlement in Ireland must be acceptable to the Conservatives because otherwise they will pull the plug
加拿大或澳大利亚。这最终实际上成为了他们的解决方案。他们不希望开创任何国家彻底分裂的先例。因为那会激励那些他们视为战略上至关重要的领地的民众，也就是埃及和印度。所以这是第一条红线。第二条红线对劳埃德·乔治来说纯粹是国内政治层面的，那就是：在爱尔兰的任何解决方案都必须是保守党能够接受的，否则他们就会撤回对他的
on his coalition. Now people who've been listening to the rest of because otherwise they will pull the plug on his coalition. Now people who've been listening to the rest of this history for a long time will remember all through this business the Conservatives have been completely committed to supporting the Protestants in the north east of Ireland in the province of Ulster and keeping them out of a Catholic dominated Irish parliament covering the whole of the island. And so does that mean in effect that Lloyd George by needing to keep the Tories on board is giving the Ulster Unionists a veto over anything he arrives at? A little bit, yes. It's slightly more complicated than that but yes, basically he can never really afford
联合政府的支持。现在，那些长期收听《历史的余烬》的人会记得，在整个事件中，保守党一直完全致力于支持爱尔兰东北部阿尔斯特省的新教徒，并让他们置于一个涵盖全岛、由天主教徒主导的爱尔兰议会之外。那么这是否意味着，劳埃德·乔治为了让保守党留在阵营中，实际上赋予了阿尔斯特统一派（Ulster Unionists）对他就任何事情达成协议的否决权？有点儿，是的。情况比这稍微复杂一点，但基本上，他永远无法真正承担起
to completely alienate the Ulster Unionists because that would alienate the Tories and it would be the end of him. By the way if Lloyd George falls the alternative is a conservative government that would be more hard line on Ireland. So Lloyd George's argument is always that I am the best that any Irish negotiating team will ever get if you don't do a deal with me the Tories definitely aren't going to do a deal with you. So in the first half of 1921 Lloyd George actually had taken quite a hard line on Ireland. He had told his colleagues again and again, he said, come on, we can sort this out, we can just let the army fight it out. But the violence had steadily got worse, as we heard from Paul last time. So in the first six months of 1921, the British had lost 93 soldiers and 223 members of the
彻底疏远阿尔斯特统一派的后果，因为那会疏远保守党，这也将是他的政治末日。顺便说一句，如果劳埃德·乔治倒台，替代他的将是一个在爱尔兰问题上更加强硬的保守党政府。因此劳埃德·乔治的论点一直是：我是任何爱尔兰谈判团队所能得到的最好结果，如果你不与我达成协议，托利党绝对不会和你们达成协议。所以在 1921 年的上半年，劳埃德·乔治实际上在爱尔兰问题上采取了相当强硬的路线。他一次又一次地对同僚们说，得了吧，我们可以解决这个问题，我们可以直接让军队去打。但正如我们上一次从保罗那里听到的那样，暴力冲突一直在恶化。所以在 1921 年的前六个月，英国损失了 93 名士兵和 223 名
Royal Irish Constabulary. Now, a point worth making, those numbers are actually really small. Yeah. I mean, it's not the Battle of the Somme, is it? No, this is such an interesting thing and I think a point really worth stressing. It's sometimes said that the British were defeated militarily in Ireland in the 1920s. That's just not right. Even the Irish Republican Army, the IRA, didn't think that they had beaten the British militarily. Because if you think about it, just a few years ago, the British were losing on a quiet
皇家爱尔兰警察（Royal Irish Constabulary）成员。现在，值得指出的是，这些数字其实非常小。是的。我的意思是，这根本不是索姆河战役，对吧？不，这是一个非常有趣的事情，我认为这是一个非常值得强调的观点。有时有人说英国人在 20 世纪 20 年代在爱尔兰在军事上被击败了。这根本不对。就连爱尔兰共和军（IRA）自己也不认为他们在军事上击败了英国。因为如果你仔细想想，就在几年前，英国人在西线战场一个平静的
day on the Western Front, they were losing easily more men than they lost in the whole of the conflict in Ireland all those years put together. But they have the manpower, they have the resources to fight in Ireland forever if they want to. It's no problem at all. But it's a really good example of how wars are political events as much as they are military ones. The issue for the British is that they just don't have the political space to keep fighting forever because the publicity from what's going on in Ireland is terrible.
日子里，他们损失的人数轻易就超过了多年来他们在爱尔兰整个冲突中损失的总人数。但他们有兵力，只要他们愿意，他们有资源在爱尔兰打到地老天荒。这根本不是问题。但这是一个极好的例子，说明了战争既是政治事件，也是军事事件。对于英国人来说，问题在于他们根本没有政治空间去永远打下去，因为爱尔兰正在发生的事情带来的负面宣传太糟糕了。
A really good example of this is all the publicity that's given to something we heard about from Paul, which is the reprisals of the auxiliaries and the black and tans. Even Churchill, who's very hardline, told his cabinet colleagues, we are getting an odious reputation. And they don't want an odious reputation. Some of the Dominion leaders, people like South Africa's Jan Smuts, are telling Lloyd George, come on, we need to fix this. Smuts says, Ireland is a chronic wound and it is poisoning our relations with the rest of the world. And Dominic also, the key relationship presumably is with America, which is now Britain's creditor. Yes. And that must diminish Britain's ability to ignore global opinion, because effectively it's
一个很好的例子就是所有关于我们从保罗那里听到的事情的宣传，也就是辅助部队（auxiliaries）和黑棕部队（Black and Tans）的报复行动。就连一向强硬的丘吉尔也对内阁同僚说：“我们正在招致一个可恶的名声。”而他们不想要一个可恶的名声。一些自治领领袖，比如南非的扬·史末ッツ（Jan Smuts），正在告诉劳埃德·乔治：得了吧，我们需要解决这个问题。史末茨说，爱尔兰是一个长期的伤口，它正在毒害我们与世界其他地方的关系。而且多米尼克，关键的交往关系想必也是与美国的交往，美国现在是英国的债权人。是的。这必定会削弱英国忽视全球舆论的能力，因为实际上这就是
American opinion. You're totally right Tom. American opinion is really important and it is also important because Lloyd George wants to conclude a naval treaty with the Americans about limiting naval spending. So that's in Washington isn't it? That's in Washington and that is massively important to him. So basically not upsetting the Americans really matters. Now what makes this even more urgent is the clock is ticking because of one of Lloyd George's own earlier attempts at a solution. So in 1920 he had passed the Government of Ireland Act and that was designed to fix the Irish issue by giving it to home
美国的舆论。你说得完全对，汤姆。美国的舆论非常重要，而且也很重要，因为劳埃德·乔治希望与美国人达成一项关于限制海军开支的海军条约。所以那是在华盛顿，对吧？那是在华盛顿，这对他来说至关重要。所以基本上，不惹恼美国人真的很重要。现在，让这件事变得更加紧迫的是，时间在流逝，因为劳埃德·乔治早些时候试图解决问题的一次尝试。所以在 1920 年，他通过了《爱尔兰政府法案》（Government of Ireland Act），旨在通过将权力下放给地方
rule parliaments. So one would be in Belfast and this would be the Parliament of Northern Ireland to govern six counties in the northeast of the island. This had been designed effectively by the Unionists themselves by their leader Sir James Craig. They didn't want the whole of the province of Ulster because they thought there were too many Catholics in it. What they wanted was just six counties because that's the maximum possible area that they can have while still having a two-thirds Protestant majority. So it's kind of geopolitical gerrymandering. A little bit, yes. So this is what becomes Northern Ireland. Now the other Home Rule Parliament would be in Dublin and
自治议会来解决爱尔兰问题。其中一个将设在贝尔法斯特，这将是北爱尔兰议会，管辖该岛东北部的六个郡。这实际上是由统一派自己及其领导人詹姆斯·克雷格爵士（Sir James Craig）设计出来的。他们不想要整个阿尔斯特省，因为他们认为里面有太多天主教徒。他们只想要六个郡，因为这是他们在保持三分之二新教多数的同时，所能拥有的最大可能区域。所以这是一种地缘政治上的杰利蝾螈（gerrymandering，不公正划选选区）。有点儿，是的。这就是后来的北爱尔兰。现在，另一个地方自治议会将设在都柏林，
that would represent the other 26 counties of Ireland and it would be called the Parliament of Southern Ireland and obviously this would have everyone knows an overwhelming Catholic majority, not Protestant. So the elections for this happened in May 1921 and they're big wins, north and south, for what you might call the sort of more extreme partisan parties. In other words, the Ulster Unionists in the north and Sinn Fein in the south. But Sinn Fein, who have won in the south, say obviously we're not going to take up our seats. We're not going to sit in a southern parliament under British rule.
它将代表爱尔兰的其他 26 个郡，被称为“南爱尔兰议会”，显然每个人都知道，这将拥有压倒性的天主教多数，而不是新教。因此，该议会的选举于 1921 年 5 月举行，南北双方都取得了大胜，获胜的是你可以称之为更极端的分裂派政党。换句话说，北方的阿尔斯特统一派和南方的芬因党（Sinn Fein）。但赢得了南方选举的芬因党表示，很显然，我们不会去占据我们的席位。我们不会在英国统治下的南方议会里开会。
That's not what we're about. The problem is that the rubric of the Act says if this parliament doesn't sit by the 12th of July, then southern Ireland will revert to a crown colony under martial law, meaning loads of troops. So by June 1921, Lloyd George's cabinet have agreed plans for a massive troop surge in Ireland and martial law across the 26 Southern counties. But the British commander in Dublin, who we heard a little bit about with Paul, General
这不是我们的主张。问题在于，该法案的规则规定，如果这个议会在 7 月 12 日之前没有开会，那么南爱尔兰将在军事管制下退化为一个皇家殖民地，这意味着将有大量的军队进驻。因此，到 1921 年 6 月，劳埃德·乔治的内阁已经批准了在爱尔兰大规模增兵并在南方 26 个郡实施军事管制的计划。但是英国驻都柏林的指挥官，我们在保罗的节目中听到过一些关于他的事，麦克雷迪将军（General
McCready. Magnificently pessimistic about Britain's prospects. Totally pessimistic, very gloomy. And he actually tells Miss Stevenson, who you quoted with your Clapham accent at the beginning of the show, he says, please will you tell Lloyd George, he must ditch the quote, the absurd idea that if you go on killing long enough, peace will ensue. I don't believe it for one moment, but I do believe that the more people that are killed, the more difficult will be the final solution.
McCready），对英国的前景感到极度的悲观。完全悲观，非常沮丧。他甚至对斯蒂芬森小姐说——也就是节目开头你用克拉珀姆口音引用的那个人——他说：“请你告诉劳埃德·乔治，他必须抛弃那个‘如果你杀戮的时间足够长，和平就会随之而来’的荒谬想法。我对此一点都不相信，但我确实相信，被杀的人越多，最终的解决方案就会越困难。”
And Dominic also, he's very contemptuous, isn't he, Macready, of the readiness of British politicians to soak up the opprobrium that would come were the army to go in and impose martial law. Yeah. He says, will they begin to howl when they hear of our shooting a hundred men in one week? Yes, exactly. I mean, and he knows his men, doesn't he? He knows that this is not something that the British government is prepared to put up with.
而且多米尼克，他对英国政客在军队进驻并实施军事管制时准备承受的骂名也感到非常蔑视，对吧？是的。他说：“当我们听到我们在一个星期内枪杀了一百人的消息时，他们会开始嚎叫吗？”是的，完全正确。我的意思是，他了解他手下的人，对吧？他知道这不是英国政府准备忍受的事情。
Exactly. So eventually Lord George gets the message and he writes to De Valera and to the prime minister of the new parliament in Belfast in the North, which has started to meet and he's called Sir James Craig. And he says, look, it's time to have a settlement settlement and this opens the door to a truce and that goes into effect on Monday the 11th of July and actually the fighting went on right to the last minute so that morning 10 people were killed before midday that day before the truce came into effect and actually the threat of bloodshed, the threat of more fighting, hangs over this whole
没错。所以最终劳埃德·乔治明白了这一点，他写信给德瓦莱拉以及北方刚刚开始开会的新贝尔法斯特议会首相詹姆斯·克雷格爵士。他说，听着，是时候达成一个解决方案了，这为休战打开了大门，休战协议于 7 月 11 日星期一生效。事实上，战斗一直持续到最后一分钟，所以在那天中午之前的那天早晨，有 10 人在休战协议生效前丧生。事实上，流血的威胁、继续战斗的威胁，从头到尾一直悬在这个整个
process from start to finish. So you don't understand how it ends without realizing that everybody basically is expecting the shooting to start again. Now another crucial point, it is always the British who control this process and Lloyd George who controls the agenda. So that meeting that we began with on the 14th of July, it's Lloyd George who sets the tone. He does that whole business with the map of the British empire. And Lloyd George is a great games player.
过程的头顶。所以如果不认识到每个人基本上都在预期枪声会再次响起，你就不会明白这一切是怎么结束的。另一个关键点是，始终是英国人在控制这个过程，是劳埃德·乔治在控制议程。所以我们在 7 月 14 日开始的那次会面，是劳埃德·乔治定下了基调。他用大英帝国的地图搞了那么一出。劳埃德·乔治是一个伟大的游戏玩家。
He's what Theo would call a windup merchant. He loves all this. He's always loved toying with people and unsettling them. So right from the start, when De Valera comes in, Lloyd George manages this huge performance about all the Dominions. He says, the Australians sit here, New Zealand sits here, Canada, and then he rests his hand on an empty chair and he says to De Valera, and this Mr De Valera is where you will sit when you become a Dominion, you know, at the top table.
他就是西奥（Theo）所说的那种喜欢挑起事端的人（windup merchant）。他喜欢这一切。他一直喜欢戏弄别人，让他们心神不定。所以从一开始，当德瓦莱拉进来时，劳埃德·乔治就关于所有的自治领进行了一场宏大的表演。他说：“澳大利亚人坐在那里，新西兰坐在那里，加拿大……”然后他把手放在一张空椅子上，对德瓦莱拉说：“德瓦莱拉先生，当你成为一个自治领时，你就会坐在那里，你知道的，坐在最高的主席台上。”
But De Valera is not going to go for that, is he? De Valera doesn't fall for it, so Lloyd George just smiles and he plays his next card. He says, The British Empire is getting rid of its difficulties and we shall soon be able to withdraw our troops from other parts of the world. Oh, I hesitate to think of the horror if the war breaks out again in Ireland. And De Valera says, Oh, that's a threat.
但德瓦莱拉可不会买账，对吧？德瓦莱拉没有上当，于是劳埃德·乔治只是笑了笑，打出了他的下一张牌。他说：“大英帝国正在摆脱它的困境，我们将很快能够从世界其他地方撤军。”“哦，如果爱尔兰再次爆发战争，我简直不敢去想那是何等的可怕。”德瓦莱拉说：“哦，这是一场威胁。
You're threatening me. Lloyd George says, No, no, no, I'm not threatening you. I'm simply forecasting what will inevitably happen if these conversations fail and if you refuse our invitation to join us and This sort of shameless games playing I have to say I do think Lord George is a bad man But I there's a sneaking admiration. I think it's fair to say yeah. Now the thing is that devil era Doesn't want a dominion. He doesn't want to be a dominion. He wants to be a republic. And this is the famous thing that Lloyd George has pointed out, isn't it?
你在威胁我。”劳埃德·乔治说：“不，不，不，我不是在威胁你。我只是在预测，如果这些对话失败，如果你拒绝我们加入我们的邀请，将不可避免地发生什么。”这种无耻的游戏心态，我必须说，我认为劳埃德·乔治是一个坏人，但我心中有一丝暗暗的赞赏。我认为这么说挺公道的。是的。问题是，德瓦莱拉不想要一个自治领。他不想成为一个自治领。他想要一个共和国。而这就是劳埃德·乔治指出的那件著名的事情，对吧？
That there is no Irish or Welsh word for republic and he knows this because he's a fellow Celt. Yes, exactly. So De Valera wants a republic. They've talked a lot about the republic, the ideals of the republic ever since 1916. But de Valera I think must know, because he's a very shrewd man, he must know that there is clearly going to be some kind of compromise. The IRA cannot win the war militarily. They can make Ireland ungovernable. They can win a political victory because they can embarrass the British and force them to talks
那就是爱尔兰语或威尔士语中没有“共和国”这个词，而他知道这一点，因为他是个同为凯尔特人的人。是的，完全正确。所以德瓦莱拉想要一个共和国。自 1916 年以来，他们一直在谈论共和国、共和国的理想。但德瓦莱拉一定知道，因为他是一个非常精明的人，他一定知道显然会有某种妥协。爱尔兰共和军在军事上无法赢得这场战争。他们可以让爱尔兰无法治理。他们可以赢得一场政治胜利，因为他们可以使英国难堪并迫使他们进行会谈，
but they know that if it actually did come to a full-scale war the British would flood the island with troops and they could kill everybody right I mean it's doable. Also de Valera knows that he's not going to get the northeast because the six counties already have a parliament up and running and Lloyd George is never going to shut that down and scrap it. That's just not realistic. Anyway, on the 20th of July, so just under a week later, the British make their formal offer. They say, Southern Ireland can be a dominion. It can be like Canada. We, the Royal Navy, will control your coasts because it's so important for Britain's security. You can't have tariffs between Ireland and Britain. What an irony,
但他们知道，如果真的爆发全面战争，英国人会用军队淹没这个岛屿，他们可以杀死所有人，对吧？我的意思是，这是做得到的。此外，德瓦莱拉知道他不会得到东北部，因为这六个郡已经有一个议会建立并运行了，而劳埃德·乔治绝不会关闭并废除它。那根本不现实。无论如何，在 7 月 20 日，也就是不到一周后，英国人提出了他们的正式报价。他们说，南爱尔兰可以成为一个自治领。它可以像加拿大一样。我们皇家海军将控制你们的海岸，因为这对于英国的安全至关重要。你们不能在爱尔兰和英国之间设立关税。多么具有讽刺意味，
the Irish want tariffs, the British don't want tariffs. And the six Ulster counties of the northeast can do their own thing, have their own parliament. Lloyd George's chief aide, Thomas Jones, we mentioned him, he's another Welshman, we'll come to him in the second half, he says this is the most generous offer in our history. And obviously de Valera says no, we want to be a republic, we don't want to be a dominion. So after a lot of toing and froing, Lloyd George says fine, why don't you come to London and we'll have a conference to discuss how the association of Ireland with the community of nations known as the British Empire can be reconciled with Irish national aspirations. And now there's a big twist. De Valera says,
爱尔兰人想要关税，英国人不想关税。东北部的六个阿尔斯特郡可以做他们自己的事，有他们自己的议会。劳埃德·乔治的首席幕僚托马斯·琼斯——我们提到过他，他也是个威尔士人，我们将在下半场谈到他——说这是我们历史上最慷慨的报价。显然，德瓦莱拉说“不”，我们想要一个共和国，我们不想成为一个自治领。所以在经过大量的拉锯战之后，劳埃德·乔治说：好吧，你为什么不来伦敦，我们开个会来讨论，爱尔兰与被称为大英帝国的国家共同体的联合，如何与爱尔兰的民族愿望相调和。现在有一个巨大的反转。德瓦莱拉说：
fine let's have these talks but I'm not coming. I will stay at home and I will send a negotiating team and then they can come back with terms and I will recommend to the revolutionary Sinn Fein assembly, the Parliament, the Doyle, I will recommend whether or not we should accept the terms that my team have brought back. Now this is a massive decision, it's probably the single most controversial decision in Irish political history that De Valera is not going to go to the talks himself because as we'll see him not going basically means they're going to have a civil war. Why doesn't he go? Historians have argued about this, different theories. First theory is that he thinks it's beneath him. He's president of the republic.
好吧，让我们进行这些会谈，但我不会去。我会呆在家里，我会派出一个谈判团队，然后他们可以带着条件回来，我会向革命性的芬因党议会——也就是道尔（Doyle），推荐我们是否应该接受我的团队带回来的条件。这是一个重大的决定，它可能是爱尔兰政治史上最具争议的单一决定，即德瓦莱拉自己不去看会谈，因为正如我们所看到的，他不去了，基本上意味着他们将会有一场内战。他为什么不去？历史学家对此争论不休，有不同的理论。第一个理论是，他认为这有失他的身份。他是共和国总统。
It's beneath him to go and negotiate with a mere prime minister like Lloyd George. Number two, that he thinks the talks will produce a compromise. He knows they will and he doesn't want to be tainted by it. He wants to maintain his purity. Number three, some people think he's frightened of Lloyd George. He's met Lloyd George. He knows Lloyd George is the world's greatest, most supple and cunning negotiator. The Welsh wizard. The Welsh wizard.
去和一个区区首相比如劳埃德·乔治谈判，是有失他的身份的。第二，他认为会谈会产生妥协。他知道会产生妥协，而他不想被其玷污。他想保持他的纯洁性。第三，有些人认为他害怕劳埃德·乔治。他见过劳埃德·乔治。他知道劳埃德·乔治是世界上最伟大、最灵活、最狡猾的谈判专家。威尔士术士（The Welsh wizard）。威尔士术士。
He doesn't want to be humiliated by him. And number four, which I think is actually very likely, De Valera thinks the talks won't produce a deal and that then with everything on the brink of disaster, he can ride in as the kind of white knight and agree a deal and he will be the hero of the hour. I think it's number two. I think he knows it's going to have to be a compromise and he doesn't want to have the moral taint of it. I think there's an element of all of these things actually.
他不想被他羞辱。第四个理论，我认为实际上很有可能，德瓦莱拉认为会谈不会产生协议，然后在一切都处于灾难边缘时，他可以像白马王子一样骑马赶来并达成协议，他将成为当之无愧的英雄。我认为是第二点。我认为他知道这将不得不是一个妥协，而他不想背上道德污点。我认为实际上所有这些因素都有一些。
I agree with you. He must know because he's not an idiot that they're not going to get what they want and he doesn't want to be tainted. So he picks an alternative team. There's a guy called Robert Barton who's from the Anglo-Irish Protestant elite. A very good example of how complicated nationalism is. Yeah. That he's from the Protestant classes.
我同意你的看法。他一定知道，因为他不是个白痴，他们不会得到他们想要的东西，而他不想被玷污。所以他挑选了一个替代团队。有一个叫罗伯特·巴顿（Robert Barton）的人，来自盎格鲁-爱尔兰新教精英阶层。这是民族主义有多么复杂的一个很好的例子。是的。他来自新教阶层。
There's a guy called Eamonn Duggan, who's a lawyer who had fought in the Easter Rising. There's a guy called George Gavin Duffy, who's another lawyer and a Sinn Féin MP. And then there's three more well-known figures. As the secretary of the delegation, he picks a man called Erskine Childers. He's a fascinating guy. Born in Mayfair in London, went to Haleybury like Clement Attlee, went to Cambridge, fought as a volunteer in the Burr War, became a British civil servant.
有一个叫埃蒙·杜根（Eamonn Duggan）的人，是一名律师，曾在复活节起义中战斗过。还有一个叫乔治·加文·达菲（George Gavin Duffy）的人，是另一位律师兼芬因党议员。然后还有三个更知名的面孔。作为代表团的秘书，他挑选了一个名叫厄斯金·奇尔德斯（Erskine Childers）的人。他是一个迷人的人物。出生于伦敦梅菲尔，和克莱门特·艾德礼（Clement Attlee）一样就读于黑利伯瑞学校（Haileybury），就读于剑桥大学，作为志愿者在布尔战争中战斗过，曾成为一名英国公务员。
He wrote the spy novel, The Riddle of the Sands, predicting the kind of First World War. But then he has this conversion experience in the 1910s, becomes a fierce critic of the empire, and basically converts to being an Irish nationalist. And he is Sinn Fein's head of publicity. So Childers is going. A man called Arthur Griffith, who we've heard a lot about, is going. He's the founder of Sinn Fein.
他写了间谍小说《沙洲谜案》（The Riddle of the Sands），预测了某种第一次世界大战。但随后他在 20 世纪 10 年代经历了这种转变体验，成为了帝国的激烈批评者，并基本上转变为了一名爱尔兰民族主义者。他是芬因党的宣传负责人。所以奇尔德斯将要前往。一个我们听过很多次的名字，亚瑟·格里菲斯（Arthur Griffith）也要去。他是芬因党的创始人。
He's this sort of short, stocky journalist and he's a nationalist icon, although he's slightly been losing ground since the Easter Rising. So Dominic, people may remember who listened to our first series on this, that Arthur Griffith was the head of the Sinn Fein and was a great fan of a dual monarchy. Yeah. The idea of the British King also being King of Ireland in the way that the Emperor in the Habsburg Empire was King of both Hungary and Austria. So is there a sense that he is more open to this idea of becoming a dominion?
他是一个矮壮的记者，也是一个民族主义偶像，尽管自从复活节起义以来他一直在失去阵地。所以多米尼克，听过我们关于这个话题的第一系列节目的听众可能还记得，亚瑟·格里菲斯曾是芬因党的领袖，并且是双元君主制的狂热崇拜者。是的。英国国王同时也兼任爱尔兰国王的想法，就像哈布斯堡帝国的皇帝既是匈牙利国王又是奥地利国王一样。那么这是否意味着他更开放于成为一个自治领的想法？
Not at first. I don't think people think he's soft on this at first at all I think none of them want to be a dominion when they all go so Griffith has left the the dual monarchy option behind now Yeah, that's history exactly and the final person somebody we've heard a lot about the head of IRA intelligence revolutionary finance minister Michael Collins. People sometimes say oh what a weird thing to send Collins when Collins is a fighting man but actually Collins hasn't done a lot of fighting. He's a strategist, he's a planner, he is a good person to choose I think and as we'll see the British end up really respecting him and thinking that he's a serious player, a serious negotiator. But at the heart of all this, there is a massive ambiguity.
一开始并没有。我不认为人们一开始认为他在这一点上心软，我认为他们所有人去的时候都不想成为自治领，所以格里菲斯现在已经把双元君主制的选项抛在脑后了。是的，那就是历史，完全正确。最后一个人，我们听到过很多有关他的人——爱尔兰共和军情报负责人、革命财政部长迈克尔·柯林斯。人们有时会说，派柯林斯去多奇怪啊，柯林斯是个好战分子。但实际上柯林斯并没有做太多战斗工作。他是一个战略家，他是一个策划者，我认为他是一个很好的选择，正如我们所看到的，英国人最终真的很尊重他，并认为他是一个严肃的玩家、一个严肃的谈判专家。但在所有这一切的核心，存在着巨大的模糊性。
De Valera says these people, he describes them explicitly as plenipotentiaries. So a plenipotentiary, for people who don't know, you send them to negotiate a deal and they can negotiate whatever they want. They do the best job they can and they don't have to come back to you to clear it with you. But in the next breath De Valera says, you're plenty pretentious, however any really big questions you must refer home before signing up to them. So any deal that you do is subject to approval but it's not really clear whether that approval will be by him and his cabinet or by the whole of the Doyle, the whole of the kind of shin feint dominated parliament so they leave.
德瓦莱拉说这些人，他明确称他们为全权代表。所以对不了解的人来说，全权代表就是你派他们去谈判达成协议，他们可以随心所欲地谈判。他们尽力做到最好，不需要回来向你请示。但在下一句话里，德瓦莱拉又说，你们虽然权力很大，但任何真正重大问题在签署之前必须呈报回国。所以你们达成的任何协议都需要批准，但目前并不清楚这个批准是由他及内阁批准，还是由整个道伊尔（Dáil，即新芬党主导的议会）批准，所以他们动身了。
With very very unclear instructions to have a free hand to negotiate whatever they want or not are they just doing devil errors bidding to have to keep going to him for his approval. going to him for his approval. They don't really know themselves and what makes this so toxic is that the republican movement in Ireland is already fracturing a bit. So previously they've been united by their opposition to Britain and their fidelity to this misty ideal of the republic. But nobody's ever really spelled out precisely what this means And so they are basically sending a very inexperienced team, people who have never really done any international negotiating at all with no clear plan about really what they want. And actually, I mean, if you think I'm being harsh, Ronan Fanning, professor of history at university college, W, he wrote a brilliant book on all this called
带着非常非常不明确的指示，既有全权谈判他们想要的自由，又不知是否只是在执行德瓦莱拉的旨意，必须不断去找他寻求批准。他们自己其实也一头雾水，而这之所以如此棘手，是因为爱尔兰的共和运动内部已经开始出现一些分裂。在此之前，他们因反对英国以及对这个虚无缥缈的共和国理想的忠诚而团结在一起。但从来没有人真正精确地阐明这意味着什么。所以他们基本上是派出了一个非常缺乏经验的团队，这些人根本没有进行过任何国际谈判，也没有关于他们真正想要的明确计划。事实上，我的意思是，如果你们觉得我言辞严厉的话，大学学院历史学教授罗南·法宁（Ronan Fanning），他写过一本关于这一切的精彩著作，书名叫
fatal path. He's unbelievably scathing about the team. He says this was a result of, and I quote, the primitive and one-dimensional politics of Doyle Aaron, which was little more than a forum where the representatives of Sinn Fein could talk to themselves. In other words, they haven't had the kind of political training, the preparation that would enable them to have a really good team and to know what they want. But isn't it profounder than that? That the notion of revolutionary violence has been sanctified over the course of the
《致命的道路》（Fatal Path）。他对这个团队的评价简直刻薄到难以置信。他说，这是“道伊尔·埃兰（Dáil Éireann）原始且单一维度的政治的结果，它不过是一个新芬党代表们自言自语的论坛”。换句话说，他们没有经过那种能够让他们拥有一个真正优秀的团队并知道自己想要的政治训练和筹备。但难道这不是比这更深层次的问题吗？那就是革命暴力的概念在整个革命过程中被神圣化了，因此谈判这一概念本身，在那些作为爱尔兰人民历史意志化身的人看来，被视为一种贬低。
revolution and therefore the very notion of negotiating is seen as demeaning for people who are the embodiments of the historic will of the Irish people. I can tell what books you've been reading Tom, because I think that's exactly right. Raymond Fanning makes that argument doesn't he? I couldn't remember Dominic, who knows. Right, that basically if you've been fighting a revolutionary war for a sort of, dare I say, a sacral ideal, the idea of sitting down around the table with your opponents and doing a deal where you do a lot of fudging and mudging kind of thing.
我能看出你一直在读什么书，汤姆，因为我觉得完全正确。雷蒙·法宁就是这么论证的，对吧？多米尼克，谁知道呢，我记不清了。好吧，基本上就是说，如果你一直在为某种——恕我直言——神圣的理想进行一场革命战争，那么和对手坐在桌子旁谈妥一项充斥着敷衍和妥协的协议的想法……
Of course, the two things are in conflict with each other. So I absolutely agree with you. Yes, I think it's very hard for them to even contemplate the idea of a deal, I would say. Well, they have turned their back on the kind of parliamentary democratic politics that Westminster represented. And of course, they are now going into the heart of Westminster to re-engage, but it's like they're, you know, they're off to play a sport that they haven't been in training for, for 10 years or something.
当然，这两者是相互冲突的。所以我完全同意你的看法。是的，我认为对他们来说，甚至去考虑达成协议的想法都非常困难。嗯，他们已经背弃了威斯敏斯特所代表的那种议会民主政治。当然，他们现在正深入威斯敏斯特的核心去重新接触，但这就像他们要去参加一项已经有十年没有训练过的运动一样。
Yeah. I think that's a fair comparison. Now, by contrast, of course, the British have been doing loads of negotiating recently, the Treaty of Versailles and all the associated treaties and their team are like a massive big hitters. Galacticos. So Lloyd George, Churchill, the conservative leader, Austin Chamberlain, the son of Joseph Chamberlain, who'd been a great foe of Irish home rule.
是的。我觉得这是一个恰当的类比。相比之下，英国人最近一直在进行大量的谈判，凡尔赛条约及所有相关的条约，他们的团队就像是一群超级巨星。银河战舰。劳合·乔治、丘吉尔、保守党领袖奥斯丁·张伯伦（约瑟夫·张伯伦的儿子，后者曾是爱尔兰地方自治的死敌）。
And somebody you mentioned, Lord Birkenhead. I mean, he's one of the biggest beasts of all. He's forgotten now, I think by and large, formerly F.E. Smith. But at the time, he is seen as large, formerly F.E. Smith. But at the time, he is seen as the most brilliant man in London. Yeah. Arrogant, hard drinking. A wit. Yeah, great wit. My favorite one is when he's a young barrister and he's speaking to a judge. He's given this huge thing and the judge says, Mr. Smith, I am none the wiser. And F.E. Smith says,
还有你提到的一个人，伯肯黑德勋爵。我的意思是，他是其中最大牌的野兽之一。我想他现在基本上已经被遗忘了，以前叫F·E·史密斯（F. E. Smith）。但在当时，他被视为伦敦最聪明的人。是的。傲傲、酗酒、机智。是的，非常机智。我最喜欢的一个故事是，当他还是个年轻的大律师时，正在跟一位法官说话。他讲了一大堆，法官说：“史密斯先生，我并没有因此变得更有智慧。”F·E·史密斯说：
no, my Lord, but you're much better informed now. Anyway, Lloyd George has picked this team. The thing is the teams are divided among themselves. Lloyd George really needs his team to stay loyal and he needs Birkenhead in particular because Birkenhead is the sort of, he's the keeper of the Tory flame, the unionist flame. If he deserts Lloyd George, Lloyd George's coalition falls apart. So he's essential to shield Lloyd George from criticism from what are called the Tory diehards.
“不，阁下，但您现在的见闻广博多了。”不管怎样，劳合·乔治挑选了这个团队。关键是这些团队内部也存在分歧。劳合·乔治非常需要他的团队保持忠诚，他尤其需要伯肯黑德，因为伯肯黑德某种程度上是托利党火焰、统一派火焰的守护者。如果他背弃了劳合·乔治，劳合·乔治的联合政府就会垮台。所以他对于保护劳合·乔治免受所谓托利党老顽固们的批评至关重要。
So this is true of the Irish as well, because they also have their own pressures and their own rivalries. Now Collins is a really good example. Collins is base with the Irish Republican Brotherhood and the Irish Republican army is a bit fragile. He has opponents. He has people who hate him. He has rivals.
爱尔兰人也是如此，因为他们也承受着自己的压力和内部竞争。柯林斯就是一个很好的例子。柯林斯在爱尔兰共和兄弟会（Irish Republican Brotherhood）和爱尔兰共和军（Irish Republican Army）的基础有点脆弱。他有反对者。有恨他的人。有竞争对手。
And so he's conscious about that. And also Collins goes to London with his personal life in massive turmoil. He's just proposed to a woman called Kitty Kiernan. Julia Roberts. Julia Roberts. Exactly. So he's got Julia Roberts on the go. The eighth of October, the Irish team arrive at Euston station.
所以他对此心知肚明。而且柯林斯去伦敦时，他的个人生活正处于极度混乱之中。他刚向一个叫基蒂·基尔南（Kitty Kiernan）的女人求婚。朱莉娅·罗伯茨。朱莉娅·罗伯茨。没错。所以他正和“朱莉娅·罗伯茨”打得火热。10月8日，爱尔兰代表团抵达尤斯顿车站。
They've gone by boat to Holyhead and then by train. Huge crowds of supporters there. Of course, a big Irish community in London. People waving flags and cheering and stuff. The one man who's not there very tellingly is Collins. That is very exciting for the British press because they see him as the kind of scarlet Pimpernel of Ireland. The most wanted man in the world.
他们先坐船到霍利黑德，然后坐火车。那里聚集了大量支持者。当然，伦敦有一个庞大的爱尔兰社区。人们挥舞着旗帜和欢呼之类的。唯一不在现场、且极具暗示性的人是柯林斯。这让英国媒体感到非常兴奋，因为他们把柯林斯视为爱尔兰的“红花侠”（Scarlet Pimpernel）。全世界最通缉的人。
All of this kind of thing. Now, he has insisted on traveling separately because he's a star. He's staying in separate lodgings from everybody else. He's got his own aides and he's got his own bodyguards. So all the others are staying in Knightsbridge behind Harrods at a place called 22 Hans Place, but he is staying in Chelsea at 15 Cadigan Gardens. So the stage is set and on the morning of Tuesday the 11th of October the Irish cars come into Downing Street. Griffith leads the way and Collins is right behind
诸如此类的事情。现在，他坚持分开旅行，因为他是明星。他和其他所有人住在不同的住处。他有自己的随从和保镖。所以其他人，都住在哈罗德百货后面的骑士桥（Knightsbridge）汉斯广场22号（22 Hans Place），但他住在切尔西的卡多根花园15号（15 Cadigan Gardens）。舞台已经搭好，10月11日星期二的早晨，爱尔兰人的汽车驶入了唐宁街。格里菲斯带头，柯林斯紧随其后，
him and there's a huge crowd having to be held back by the police. Everyone's very excited. The black door number 10 opens and inside Lord George is waiting to shake their hands. Gentlemen nice to see you. Just after 11 o'clock they take their places around the cabinet table. William Gladstone the first British Prime Minister to try to solve in inverted commas the Irish question. That was his table. So they're sitting around the table. Lloyd George very smiley all business he says, gentlemen the time has come to end the tragic
外面有大批群众被警察拦在后面。大家都非常兴奋。10号那扇黑色的门打开了，劳合·乔治正等在里面和他们握手。“先生们，很高兴见到你们。”刚过11点，他们在内阁会议桌旁就座。威廉·格莱斯顿（William Gladstone），第一位试图解决带引号的“爱尔兰问题”的英国首相。那张桌子就是他的。所以他们围坐在桌旁。劳合·乔治满脸笑容，开门见山地说：“先生们，结束这段充满误解和战争的悲剧历史的时候到了。”
story of misunderstanding and war. And with that Tom the real drama begins. Well we will be back after a break to hear how things go. Hello everyone it's Gary Lineker here from The Rest Is Football. Just a quick message to tell you all about the Club World Cup tournament that's taking place in the US at the moment. It's 32 of the best teams from all around the world battling it out to be crowned the best side on the planet.
伴随着这个，汤姆，真正的戏剧性就要开始了。好吧，我们休息一下再听听事情进展如何。大家好，我是来自《足球就是全部》（The Rest Is Football）的加里·莱因克尔。简单向大家宣布一个消息，关于目前正在美国举办的世俱杯锦标赛。来自世界各地的32支最佳球队正在那里奋力拼搏，争夺地球上最佳球队的桂冠。
We've reached the knockout stages of the competition which means all the big guns will be going head to head. Manchester City, Real Madrid, PSG, Chelsea and Bayern Munich are just some of the sides vying to lift the trophy. Join myself, Alan Shearer, Michael Richards and our expert out in America, Alex Aljoe, as we guide you through the explosive final stages of the tournament. To make things even better,
我们已经进入了比赛的淘汰赛阶段，这意味着所有的大佬们都将展开正面交锋。曼城、皇马、巴黎圣日耳曼、切尔西和拜仁慕尼黑只是其中几支争夺奖杯的球队。快来加入我、阿兰·希勒、迈克尔·理查兹以及我们在美国的前方专家亚历克斯·阿尔霍（Alex Aljoe），让我们带您了解赛事惊心动魄的最后阶段。为了让体验更好，
if you're watching the video version of the show on Spotify or YouTube, you can also watch all the goals and the best bits of the action as we discuss the games of first for podcasting. Just search the rest is football wherever you get your podcasts. Hello, welcome back to the rest is history. We are in Downing Street on the morning of the 11th October 1921 and David Lloyd George, the Welsh wizard, his mustache bristling, his eyes twinkling is holding court.
如果您在Spotify或YouTube上观看节目的视频版本，您还可以一边收听我们对比赛的讨论，一边观看所有的进球和精彩片段，这在播客中尚属首次。无论您在哪里收听播客，只需搜索“the rest is football”即可。哈喽，欢迎回到《历史就是全部》（The Rest Is History）。我们正身处1921年10月11日早晨的唐宁街，大卫·劳合·乔治——这位威尔士巫师，他的胡子根根竖起，他的双眼闪闪发光——正在高谈阔论。
Yes. Dominic, what is he saying? So he says, look, we can end the cycle of violence. He says, but we have to hurry There are forces at work in this country which think the government has gone too far already In other words, there's an element of a threat there right from the beginning So these are the Tory diehards these are the Tory diehards now next person to speak is Arthur Griffith Who's the sort of head of the Irish delegation and he says, you know You've treated us badly since the days of
是的。多米尼克，他在说些什么？所以他说，听着，我们可以结束暴力循环。他说，但我们必须抓紧时间，这个国家有股势力认为政府已经走得太远了。换句话说，从一开始就带有某种威胁的成分。所以这些就是托利党的老顽固们，这些就是托利党的老顽固们。接下来发言的是阿瑟·格里菲斯（Arthur Griffith），他是爱尔兰代表团的某种负责人，他说，你知道的，自从威廉·皮特（William Pitt）时代以来，你们一直这样对待我们，我希望我们现在能把这一切抛在脑后。
William Pitt and I hope that we will now put that all behind us. But in a sort of nicely symbolic moment, Griffith speaks so quietly that many of the British can't actually hear what he's saying and Gretchen Freeman, who's written an actually incredibly readable book on the treaty, you wouldn't think that this is a very readable subject, but she does brilliantly this sort of popular narrative. She says it was as though a lion had given way to a mouse when Griffith is speaking. And this sort of sets the tone because almost every historian, British or Irish, who's written
但在一个颇具象征意义的时刻，格里菲斯说话声音太小，以至于许多英国人根本听不清他在说什么。格雷琴·弗里曼（Gretchen Freeman）——她写了一本关于这项条约的、实际上极其易读的书，你不会觉得这是一个很容易阅读的题材，但她以这种大众叙事的方式写得非常出色——她说，当格里菲斯发言时，就像是一头狮子向一只老鼠妥协。这为整场会谈定下了基调，因为几乎所有写过这段历史的英国或爱尔兰历史学家都说，爱尔兰人在开始时看起来非常紧张，也毫无准备。
about this says, the Irish at the beginning, they seem very nervous and very unprepared. And the difference is the British are, you know, they're bulldozers They know exactly what they want to get and how to get it and anyone Dominic who has lived through the brexit negotiations Will find echoes of that process throughout this. Yeah, absolutely and the Irish are playing the part of the British negotiators and The British are in the position of the EU. They hold the cards, they're familiar. Yeah, it's exactly that. When I was reading about this, I was thinking about it every turn.
而不同之处在于，英国人，你知道的，他们就像是推土机，他们确切地知道自己想得到什么以及如何得到它。多米尼克，任何经历过脱欧谈判的人都会在整个过程中发现这种回响。是的，绝对如此。爱尔兰人在扮演英国谈判代表的角色，而英国人则处于欧盟的立场。他们手牌更好，而且轻车熟路。是的，完全就是这样。当我读到这段历史时，我每时每刻都在这么想。
You know, one side knows exactly what they want and what their red lines are, and the others are divided among themselves and don't really know exactly what they want. So a good example is, at this very first meeting, Griffith says, we're thinking that maybe Ireland will be neutral. And Lloyd George just says, I'm going to shut that down right now. You're never going to be neutral. We will never accept this.
你知道，一方确切地知道他们想要什么以及他们的红线在哪里，而另一方内部四分五裂，根本不知道自己到底想要什么。一个很好的例子是，在第一次会议上，格里菲斯就说，我们在考虑爱尔兰也许会保持中立。而劳合·乔治直截了当地说，我现在就要打破这个幻想。你们永远不可能保持中立。我们绝不会接受这一点。
We want you to be like Canada, and Canada definitely is neutral. The next thing, in these first meetings, Griffith and Collins in particular spent a lot of time talking about a united Ireland. How are we going to get this six counties back? But almost every historian has written about this, says this is a complete waste of time. Partition is irreversible. It's arguably partition has been on the cards for about 12 years. Well, certainly since 1912, let's say. There's no way that Lloyd George is going to shut down the parliament
我们希望你们像加拿大一样，而加拿大绝对是……好吧，加拿大当然是中立的（注：原文此处口误，加拿大1931年才独立，但演讲者随口说错）。接下来，在这些早期的会议中，格里菲斯和柯林斯特别花了大量时间讨论一个统一的爱尔兰。我们该如何把这六个郡拿回来？但几乎所有写过这段历史的历史学家都说，这完全是在浪费时间。分治已成定局，不可逆转。可以说，分治的问题大约在12年前就已经提上日程了。好吧，至少可以说从1912年起就是这样。劳合·乔治绝不可能关闭贝尔法斯特的议会，因为那会激怒托利党并摧毁他的政府。
in Belfast because it would inflame the Tories and destroy his government. So they're wasting their time going on about this unless they're using it in a cunning way as a bargaining chip to get something else, which as we'll see they're not really. Anyway, the talks drag on and quite soon the British say, look, we've run out of patience. So on Friday the 21st of October, Lloyd George says, okay, enough. I want answers on three things. Allegiance to the crown, you have to still acknowledge the king, you have to still be members of the empire and we want naval defence guarantees, i.e. we will basically be in charge of your
所以他们在这个问题上喋喋不休纯粹是在浪费时间，除非他们是在耍小聪明，把它当作讨价正如我们所见，他们其实并没有这么做。无论如何，谈判一拖再拖，很快英国人就说，听着，我们已经失去耐性了。因此在10月21日星期五，劳合·乔治说，好了，够了。我需要对三件事给出答案。对王室的效忠，你们必须仍然承认国王；你们必须仍然是帝国的成员；我们想要海军防务保证，也就是说，我们将基本上负责你们的安保。如果你们周一前不给我们答复，谈判就结束，我们重回战端。
security and if you don't give us the answer by Monday, the talks are over and we're back to the war. So the following Monday, at long last, the Irish team come up with a counteroffer and this has been drafted by De Valera himself and this is an idea called external association. So Ireland will be a neutral republic, they're still going with that, but it will be associated with the British Empire. It won't be a member of the British Empire but it will be associated with it. You've put in your notes all very reminiscent of Brexit negotiations, endless hair splitting
于是在接下来的星期一，爱尔兰代表团终于提出了一份反建议，这是由德瓦莱拉本人起草的，这个想法被称为“外部联系”（external association）。因此，爱尔兰将是一个中立共和国，他们仍然坚持这一点，但它将与大英帝国保持联系。它不会是大英帝国的成员，但会与之相关联。你在笔记里写道，这非常让人想起脱欧谈判，对那些对极少数人有着巨大意义的微小宪法细节进行无休止的咬文嚼字。我的意思是，这完全就是那么回事，对吧？
about tiny constitutional details that matter enormously to quite small numbers of people. I mean, that's exactly what it's like, isn't it? Yeah, it is. Exactly. I don't think that the average person in Ireland is really excited about whether it's a Dominion or external association or those things. But if you're a nationalist, of course, if you've fought and if you've lost people in the war, of course it matters.
是的，确实如此。完全是这样。我认为爱尔兰的普通民众其实并不太关心这到底是自治领（Dominion）还是外部联系或诸如此类的事情。但如果你是一个民族主义者，当然，如果你曾经历过战争并失去了亲人，这当然意义重大。就像如果你是2016年“脱欧”阵营的一员，你就会真正关心脱欧谈判的结果一样。劳合·乔治对“外部联系”的想法表现得极其蔑视。事实上，再次正如大多数历史学家所认为的那样，英国人是绝不会接受这一点的。有一位爱尔兰历史学家叫比尔·卡萨恩（Bill Cassane），他指出，英国人赢得第一次世界大战可不是为了在自家后院面对羞辱。又是一次一战的类比。
Just as if you were somebody who'd been in the Leave campaign in 2016, you really care about the outcome of the Brexit talks. Lloyd George treats the idea of external association with utter contempt. And actually, actually again most historians think the British are never going to go for this. There's an Irish historian called Bill Cassane. The British didn't win the First World War to contemplate humiliation in their own backyard. Again the First World War comparison. And what is more, what's really interesting and more surprise people, the other Dominions will not accept it either. So Canada and Australia, for example, have made it very clear to London they expect Ireland to remain within the Empire.
而且更重要的是，真正有趣且会让人们感到惊讶的是，其他自治领也不会接受它。例如，加拿大和澳大利亚已经向伦敦明确表示，他们期望爱尔兰留在帝国之内。如果爱尔兰人作为中立共和国走自己的路，他们是不会高兴的。所以，你知道的，帝国是如此脆弱。在20世纪20年代初，它的疆域达到了历史最大。但它看起来又是如此摇摇欲坠，而劳合·乔治一直在考虑这一点。无论如何，他们在周一举行了这次会议，会后劳合·乔治对柯林斯和格里菲斯说：“你们两个能留下来私下聊聊吗？”现在，如果爱尔兰代表团更明智一些的话，
They will not be happy if the Irish go their own way as a neutral republic. So, you know, the Empire is so fragile. It's at its largest ever extent in the early 1920s. But it seems so delicately poised, and Lloyd George is always thinking about this. Anyway, they have this meeting on the Monday, and afterwards Lloyd George says to Collins and Griffiths, could you two stay behind please for a private chat? Now, if the Irish team had been more sensible,
他们绝不会和劳合·乔治进行私人谈话。他们绝不会让自己被诱惑进去，因为这样做会瓦解他们的团队。劳合·乔治在小型会议上表现得极为出色。他是个操纵高手，能够玩弄人心之类。随着时间的推移，他进行了越来越多的这种私下谈话。他将格里菲斯和柯林斯认作他所喜欢的、能够与之做生意的人，而他们两人都开始对英国人产生好感——这绝对是始料未及的事。所以格里菲斯甚至在某封信中写信给德瓦莱拉说，你知道的，我认为如果我们对英国人表现出多一点善意，他们会给我们很多好处。
they would never have had private chats with Lloyd George. They would never have allowed themselves to be seduced into this because what it does is it splinters their team and Lloyd George is brilliant in small meetings. He's a manipulator, he can play on people and stuff and as time goes on he has more and more of these private chats. He identifies Griffith and Collins as the people that you know he likes and he can do business with and they both to warm to the British, the one thing that you would never have expected. So Griffith actually writes to De Valera at one point and he says, you know, I think if
你会觉得这太疯狂了，你简直是中了英国人的迷魂汤。真正引人注目的是，柯林斯——爱尔兰共和军的情报主管——他也开始对英国人的迷魂汤产生好感。真正引人注目的是，柯林斯——爱尔兰共和军的情报主管——他也开始对英国人产生好感。你知道的，他真正能谈得来、并取得突破的人是伯肯黑德勋爵，即F·E·史密斯。是的，完全没错。他认为因为他们都是纯粹的男子汉、阿尔法男，他们喜欢霸凌别人，喜欢喝酒，喜欢吃生蚝或者诸如此类的事。是的，他们喜欢开玩笑。而且事实上，柯林斯开始稍微早一点到达会场，这样他就可以和伯肯黑德勋爵开点玩笑了。
we show a little bit more goodwill to the British, they'll give us a great deal. Which you would think, that's mad, you've just drunk the British Kool-Aid. The really remarkable thing is that Collins, the IRA's head of intelligence, he also starts to warm to the British Kool-Aid. The really remarkable thing is that Collins, the IRA's head of intelligence, he also starts to warm to the British. And you know, the person he really like gets somewhere with Lord Birkenhead, F.E. Smith. Yeah, exactly. He thinks because they're men's men, they're alpha males, they like bullying people, they like drinking, they like eating oysters or whatever. Yeah, they like bants. And and actually Collins starts getting to the meetings a little bit early so they can have a bit of banter with Lord Birkenhead.
我太喜欢这个了。那是你梦想中的晚宴嘉宾对吧？迈克尔·柯林斯和F·E·史密斯。是的。另一个在改变这种情绪中发挥重要作用的人，我们简要提到过他，就是这个人，汤姆·琼斯（Tom Jones），这个威尔士人。现在没有人知道他了，但在这个人——汤姆·琼斯，这个威尔士人。现在没有人知道
I love that. That's your dream dinner party, right? Michael Collins and F.E. Smith. Yeah. So the other person who's really important in this change in the mood, we mentioned him briefly, it's this guy, Tom Jones, this Welshman. Now nobody knows about him today, but in this guy Tom Jones, this Welshman. Now nobody knows
他了，但在20世纪20年代，他是终极的操盘手。一家报纸称他是欧洲六个最有权势的人之一，这是一个很高的评价。我很想知道另外五个是谁。是的，他是工人阶级出身，也会说威尔士语，他曾是一名福音派传教士，现在已成为副内阁秘书，也是劳合·乔治的得力助手。基本上，劳合·乔治很喜欢用威尔士语跟他聊天。他们会在其他人面前非常显眼、极其招摇地用威尔士语交谈，以此来惹恼别人。这是我私下里其实也很欣赏劳合·乔治的另一件事，因为如果我会说威尔士语的话，我也会一直那么做。
about him today but in the 1920s he was the ultimate operator. One newspaper called him one of the six most powerful people in Europe, which is a big claim. I'd love to know who the other five were. Yeah, he's working class, he's also Welsh speaking, he's a former evangelical preacher and he's now become the Deputy Cabinet Secretary and he is Lloyd George's right hand man. Basically doesn't like George chat to him in Welsh. They're talking Welsh in front of other people kind of very ostentatiously ostentatiously to annoy. This is another thing that actually I secretly really admire about Lloyd George, because I would, if I could speak Welsh, I would do that all the time.
所以汤姆·琼斯，大家都喜欢他。他非常……当爱尔兰代表团真的非常喜欢他时，劳合·乔治把他用作关键的中间人。他派汤姆·琼斯去格罗夫纳酒店（Grosvenor Hotel）与柯林斯和格里菲斯进行另一次这样的小型会谈。琼斯说，听着，你们一直喋喋不休地谈论一个统一的爱尔兰会毁了这次会谈，因为政府永远不会抛弃阿尔斯特统一派，但有一个解决办法，他说，有一个解决办法可以解决这个问题。现在在20世纪20年代，重新划分边界是全城热议的话题。曾经有过一场巨大的争端，
So Tom Jones, everybody likes him. He's very like when the Irish team really like him and Lloyd George uses him as a key go between. And he sends Tom Jones to the Grosvenor Hotel for another of these little meetings with Collins and Griffith. And Jones says, look, you going on about United Island is going to destroy these talks because the government will never abandon the Ulster Unionists, but there is an answer, he says, there's an answer that could fix this. Now redrawing borders is all the rage in the 1920s. There has been a big dispute
虽然今天完全被遗忘了，但在整个1921年一直占据着头条新闻，那就是德国和波兰在上西里西亚（Upper Silesia）的争端。琼斯说，为什么我们不效仿他们在西里西亚的做法呢？他们有一个划界委员会来画出一条新边界。你知道，如果我们有一个划界委员会，我估计那个划界委员会会给你们大量的领土。你们会得到这六个郡中天主教徒占多数的泰隆郡（Tyrone）和费尔马纳郡（Fermanagh）等地的部分。你们为什么不这么做呢？
which is totally forgotten today but has dominated the headlines all through 1921 between Germany and Poland in Upper Silesia. And Jones says why don't we do what they did in Silesia? They had a boundary commission that drew a new border. You know, if we had a boundary commission, I reckon that boundary commission would give you loads of territory. You would get the bits of the six counties that are very Catholic in Tyrone and Femana and stuff. Why don't you do that?
格里菲斯说，哦，是的，这其实是个挺不错的主意。我喜欢这个主意。谁会进入这个划界委员会？谁来运营它？嗯，这就是问题所在，并没有明确定义。劳合·乔治在这方面太狡猾了。我的意思是，剧透一下，划界委员会的想法得以实行，
And Griffith says, oh yeah, that's actually quite a good idea. I love that idea. Who would be on this boundary commission? Who would run it? Well, this is the thing, it's not defined. Lloyd George is so cunning with all this. I mean, spoiler alert, the boundary commission idea flies,
但从未真正产生任何结果。这是因为劳合·乔治对此进行了深思熟虑。这个承诺——哦，划界委员会可以给你大量的领土——它就悬在那里，但也有另一种可能性，划界委员会也可能会从你们手中夺走领土，而这一点从未被真正讨论过。现在，当格里菲斯说“哦，是的，我们可以这么做”时，这是一个非常重要的时刻，因为他第一次违背了都柏林德瓦莱拉给他的指示。他开始发挥自己的主动性，我想这是德瓦莱拉绝没料到他会做的事。
but never really produces anything. And this is because Lloyd George has really thought this through. And this promise, oh, the boundary commission could give you loads of new territory it's hanging there but there is also another possibility the boundary commission could take territory from you and this is never really discussed. Now when Griffith says oh yeah we could do that, this is a really important moment for the first time he's going against his instructions
然后第二天他与劳合·乔治会面，劳合·乔治表现得最为狡猾。他说，托利党媒体给我制造了这么大的麻烦，那些托利党老顽固们。我想我的联合政府实际上可能会崩溃。我真的需要你们的帮助。我需要说服阿尔斯特统一派接受这个划界委员会的想法。
from De Valera in Dublin. He's using his own initiative, which I think De Valera never expected him to do. And then the next day he has a meeting with Lloyd George and Lloyd George is at his most serpentine. He says the Tory press are giving me such a hard time, the Tory diehards. I think my coalition might break up actually. And I really need your help. I need to persuade the Ulster unionists about this boundary commission idea.
所以请不要公开驳斥它。不要攻击它。就假装你们喜欢它，暂时先接受它。格里菲斯对他说，好吧，没问题。我理解，你知道的，我不是现在就同意它，但我不会诋毁它。劳合·乔治说，太棒了。第二天，他派了那个叫琼斯的家伙去，琼斯说，首相让我顺便送一份文件，上面描述了昨天关于划界委员会的会议。你介意在上面签个同意吗？格里菲斯扫了一眼这份文件说，好的，行。看起来不错。看起来不错。现在，这是关键时刻。
So please don't dismiss it publicly. Don't attack it. Just pretend that you like it and live with it for the time being. And Griffith says to him, okay, fine. I understand, you know, I'm not agreeing to it now, but I won't slack it off. Aloy George, he says, yeah, brilliant. And the next day he sends this guy Jones and Jones says, the prime minister's asked me to drop a document describing yesterday's meeting about the Boundary Commission. Do you mind just agreeing to it? And Griffith glances at this document and he says, yeah, fine. Looks good. Looks good. Now, this is a key moment.
当琼斯回去报告说“是的，他对这很满意”时，劳合·乔治欣喜若狂。弗朗西斯·史蒂文森（Frances Stevenson）那天晚上说，我从来没见过他为什么事这么兴奋过。而且她肯定见过他为不少事情兴奋过。我想她确实见过他兴奋的样子。是的。因为这份文件起了两个作用。第一，劳合·乔治巩固了自己的侧翼，抵御了托利党老顽固们的攻击。
When Jones gets back and says, yes, he's fine with it. Lloyd George is delighted. And Frances Stevenson says that night, I have never seen him so excited about anything before. And she must have seen him excited about quite a lot of things. I would think she certainly has seen him excited. Yes. Because this document has done two things. Number one, Lord George has shored up his flank against the Tory diehards.
他可以去找他们说，看，我已经说服了这个新芬党人同意划界委员会。也就是实际上同意了分治。但同时，他也计划把这份文件存档，以便日后用来对抗格里菲斯，正如我们所见。因此，英国人起草了一份条约草案，这非常符合他们之前已经讨论过的大方向：爱尔兰成为一个自治领，北爱尔兰走自己的路，并且设立这个划界委员会。当爱尔兰代表团看到这份条约草案时，他们中的一些人简直
He can go to them and say, look, I've persuaded this bloke from Sinn Fein to agree to the boundary commission. So effectively to agree to partition. But also he plans to store this document away and to use it against Griffith later, as we shall see. So the British produce a draft treaty this is very much along the lines that they'd already discussed Ireland becomes a Dominion, Northern Ireland does its own thing and there's this Boundary Commission. When the Irish team see this draft treaty some of them go
气炸了。什么？爱尔兰仍然在帝国之内，仍然在国王之下？我们绝不接受这个。但柯林斯已经开始改变想法了。他一直在大量阅读关于自治领的书籍。他意识到的一点是——而且我认为他完全是对的——成为一个像加拿大或澳大利亚那样的自治领，并不是一个终点。它是一个过程。换句话说，他意识到，例如，加拿大将成为一个完全独立的国家，然后它正处于一条不可避免地通往该地位的传送带上。他说，看，这显然也会发生在加拿大和澳大利亚身上，所以如果我们踏上这条传送带，这也会发生在我们的身上。我们不会马上得到我们想要的，但我们最终会得到的。延迟满足。延迟满足。
absolutely ballistic. What Ireland's still in the Empire, still under the crown, no way are we having this. But Collins has already begun to change his mind. He's been doing loads of reading on the Dominions. And one thing he realises, and I think he's quite right, is that being a Dominion, like Canada or like Australia, is not an end point. It's a process. So in other words, he realises that Canada, for example, is going to become a completely independent country and then it's on a sort of conveyor belt that is leading it inexorably towards that status. And he says, look, that's clearly going to happen to Canada and Australia, so that would
现在，爱尔兰代表团为此激烈争论到深夜，这意味着他们第二天出席全体会议时精疲力竭。与此同时，劳合·乔治不断施加压力。他说，来吧，我们需要快点做决定。我不想重启战争，但如果必须的话，我会的。快点，快点。他不停地对他们说，你们必须接受帝国中自治领的地位，你们必须接受帝国中自治领的地位，你们必须接受国王。
happen to us too if we get on this conveyor belt. We won't get what we want straight away, but we'll get it eventually. Delayed gratification. Delayed gratification. Now the Irish team are arguing bitterly about this long into the night, which of course means they're knackered the next day when they turn up for the full meetings. And all the time, Lloyd George is piling on the pressure. He said, come on, we need to decision quickly.
这意味着爱尔兰议员（或按他们现在的称呼TD，即议会成员）必须向宪法和国王陛下宣誓效忠。这又是如此“脱欧”，不是吗？太像脱欧了。
I don't want to restart the war, but I will if I have to. Hurry up, hurry up. And he keeps saying to them, you must accept the status of a dominion in the empire and you must accept the status of a dominion in the empire and you must accept the king. And that means the Irish MPs or TDs as they've become would have to swear an oath of allegiance to the constitution and to his majesty. And again, it's so Brexit, isn't it? It's so Brexit.
这简直就像是强硬派脱欧谈判代表在意识形态上的坚定决心，绝不与欧盟的司法框架或监督控制等有任何瓜葛，这更多是一个原则问题，而不是政治问题。当然，但原则很重要。当然。我的意思是，原则对人们来说极其重要。现在有趣的是，劳合·乔治说，听着，如果你们不喜欢这样，我们会
It's exactly like the kind of ideological determination on the part of the hardline Brexit negotiators not to have anything to do with EU frameworks of justice or supervisory controls or anything like that and more a point of principle than of politics. Of course, but principle matters. Of course. Yeah. I mean principle matters enormously to people. Now the interesting thing is, Lloyd George says, look, if you don't like this, we will
彻底击垮你们。我们会重新派驻军队，把你们全杀了。他在虚张声势吗？我觉得他其实没有虚张声势。有些历史学家认为他是。但我认为——劳合·乔治是个在第一次世界大战最血腥的日子里，安然坐在政府内阁担任首相的人。他完全有能力派成千上万的军队去爱尔兰战斗、死去和杀戮。我认为，正如我们将会看到的，格里菲斯和柯林斯都完全相信，如果迫不得已，他真的会重启战争。所以让我们进入12月的第一周，这是劳合·乔治设定的最后期限。
smash you. We will reintroduce troops and we will kill you all Is he bluffing? I don't think he is bluffing actually some historians think he was But I think I mean Lloyd George is a man who was sat there quite happily in government as prime minister During the bloodiest days of the first world war. He's perfectly capable of sending Thousands of troops to fight and die and to kill in ireland I think and as we will see griffith and conan Collins both completely believe that he would restart the war if he had to. So let's move towards the first week in December, which is the deadline that Lloyd George has
所以我们迎来了12月3日的第一个星期六，爱尔兰代表团回到了都柏林。他们去会见了德瓦莱拉和他的内阁。他们到得很晚，他们的船在爱尔兰海与一艘双桅帆船相撞了，所以他们精疲力竭。这非常像《沙之谜》（The Riddle of the Sands），不是吗？非常像《沙之谜》。他们一路都在争吵。格里菲斯说，看，这是我们能得到的最好的结果了。每个人都渴望和平，我们只能接受王室、帝国和宣誓。巴顿（Barton）和加文·达菲（Gavin Duffy）说，不，这全是废话。英国人在虚张声势，他们绝不会再次挑起战争。
set. So we're on the first Saturday of December the third, the Irish team are back in Dublin. They've gone to meet De Valera and his cabinet. They get there very late, their boat collided with a schooner in the Irish sea, so they're knackered. That's very riddle of the sands, isn't it? Very riddle of the sands. They've been bickering all the way. Griffith says, look, this is the best we're going to get. Everybody wants peace, we just have to suck up the crown and the empire and the oath. Barton and Gavin Duffy say, no, that's rubbish. The British are bluffing they'll never start the war again.
柯林斯态度有点暧昧。他说，我不喜欢这个誓言。我对这个协议不满意。但——我引述一下——“英国可以在一周内在爱尔兰挑起一场战争。”德瓦莱拉当然在这个过程中从未踏足伦敦。他这样说，而我认为你应该回伦敦。为什么你不再试着推销一下我的“外部联系”的想法呢？你可以想象那种情景。
Collins is a bit ambiguous. He says, I don't like the oath. I'm not happy about the deal. But and I quote, England could arrange a war in Ireland within a week. De Valera of course, has still not set foot in London during this process. Says this, and I think you should go back to London. Why don't you try pushing my external association idea again? You can imagine that.
哦，天哪，拜托。他至关重要地说道——这对于解释我们接下来要做的几集里发生的事情非常重要——德瓦莱拉说：“请随时让我和我的内阁了解最新情况。在没有与我协商一致之前，绝对不要签署任何东西。”罗伯特·巴顿这时对他说：“你为什么不和我们一起去？和我们一起去伦敦吧。”德瓦莱拉说：“不，不，不，我在这里挺好的。
Oh God, come on. And he says crucially, this is really important to explain what happens in the next couple of episodes that we'll do. De Valera says, please keep me and my cabinet in the loop. Do not sign anything without agreeing it with me. And Robert Barton at this point says to him, why will you not come with us? Come with us to London. And de Valera says, no, no, no, I'm actually fine here.
我在这里非常高兴。”因为在我看来，德瓦莱拉最不愿妥协的，正是他对自己美德的自我感觉。雷南·法宁在他的书里引用了一段精彩的评论，他引用了参与谈判的英国官员莱昂内尔·柯蒂斯（Lionel Curtis）的话。柯蒂斯对英国人这样说：“英国人民最大的力量在于他们根深蒂固的信念，即无论发生什么，他们和他们的领导人都会犯下可怕的错误。”然后他说：“新芬党政府最大的弱点在于，它几乎
I'm quite happy here. Because it seems to me that what de Valera doesn't want to compromise with more than anything is his own sense of his own virtue. And there's an amazing comment that Renan Fanning quotes in his book, and he quotes Lionel Curtis, who is a British official, involved in the negotiations. And Curtis has said of the British, the greatest strength of the British people lies in their inveterate belief that whatever else happens, they and their leaders will blunder horribly. And then he says, the greatest weakness of the Sinn Fein government is that it is almost
无法向世界承认他们自己会思考错误或做出错误的事情。”在我看来，这实际上与谈判中的那些治理原则高度吻合。事实上，我的意思是，它也与脱欧谈判相当吻合。难道这就是一个主要由务实主义驱动的团队——他们并不觉得道德在其中扮演任何角色——与另一个真正相信自己站在正义、美德、自由、独立等诸如此类的一边的团队之间的区别吗？
void of any admission to the world of themselves themselves that they can either think what is wrong or do what is wrong. And that seems to me actually to map very well onto the kind of the governing principles in the negotiations. And actually, I mean, it also maps on quite well onto the Brexit negotiations as well. Isn't it the difference between one team that's motivated largely by pragmatism and they have no sense that this is a process in which morality plays any part at all and another team who genuinely believe that they're on the side of rights and virtue and freedom and independence
因此，任何妥协都将是非常困难的。我认为这必然是其中很大的一部分。无论如何，到周日晚上他们回到了伦敦，也就是12月4日，他们再次回到唐宁街，大概是第5000次就爱尔兰分治和对王室效忠宣誓的问题争论不休。劳合·乔治现在完全处于一种表演式的、情节剧般的精神状态。他有点像说，我们必须开个闭门会议，我和我的团队。
and all of those kinds of things. So any compromise is going to be very difficult. I think that must be a huge part of it. Anyway by the Sunday evening they're back in London, that's the 4th of December, they go back to Downing Street, yet again, about the 5,000th time they have an argument about the partition of Ireland and the oath to the Crown. And Lloyd George now is just in pure kind of performative melodramatic mood. He kind of says, we're gonna have to have a private meeting, me and my team.
他们出去开了个闭门会议。然后他又进来了。我的意思是，他们可能只是出去抽根烟什么的。然后他们走进来，劳合·乔治对爱尔兰人说：“听着，如果你们不愿加入帝国，如果你们不愿接受王室这个共同的纽带，那么恐怕这意味着战争。事情就是这样。”他在虚张声势吗？
They go out and have a private meeting. And then he comes back in. I mean, they're probably just going out for a smoke or something. And then they come back in and Lloyd George says to the Irish, listen, if you won't enter the empire, if you won't accept the common bond of the crown, then I'm afraid this means war. You know, that's how it is. And is he bluffing?
我不认为他在虚张声势。第二天早上，即周一的5号，他的团队准备了一份关于谈判破裂的声明草案。他们将所有责任都推卸给新芬党，并向爱尔兰的军队发出了加密电报，称“准备在几天内迎接敌对行动”。当天晚些时候，劳合·乔治要求单独见柯林斯，他们并没有决定任何事，但劳合·乔治通过这样做，显然是在向柯林斯传达一个信息。你是一个严肃的人，我的意思是，来吧，我们可以解决这个问题。帮我解决它。下午把其他人带来，我们将召开最后一次会议，我们再做最后一次尝试。
I don't think he is. The next morning, Monday the 5th, his team prepare a draft statement on the collapse of the talks. They put all the blame on Sinn Fein and team prepare a draft statement on the collapse of the talks. They put all the blame on Sinn Fein and they send a coded message to the army in Ireland saying prepare for hostilities within days. Later that morning, Lloyd George asks to see Collins alone and they don't decide anything but Lloyd George by doing that is clearly sending Collins I think a message. You are a serious person, I mean come, we can fix this. Help me to fix it. Bring the others this afternoon and we'll have one last meeting and we'll have one last
于是那天下午三点，爱尔兰代表团返回唐宁街参加这最后一次会议。气氛非常紧张。这一次没有挥舞着旗帜的欢呼人群或类似的东西。他们没钱了。所以他们第一次到达时，坐了许多辆车。这次他们不得不挤进一辆车里，全都坐在彼此的膝盖上。这是一次非常不体面的抵达。英国人精简了他们的团队。桌对面只有四个人。有劳合·乔治、丘吉尔、伯肯黑德勋爵，还有保守党领袖奥斯丁·张伯伦。
go. So that afternoon, three o'clock, the Irish delegates returned to Downing Street for this last meeting. It's a very tense mood. This time there are no cheering crowds with flags or anything like that. They've run out of money. So the first time they ever arrived, they arrived in multiple cars. This time they all have to cram into one car, all sitting on each other's laps. It's a very indecorous arrival. And the British have slimmed down their team. So there's just four people facing them at the table. There's Lloyd George, there is Churchill, there's Lord Birkenhead and there's Austin
丘吉尔事后说：“死神就站在我们的肘边。”是的，因为他们确实认为明天可能就要打仗了。接下来发生的事情是劳合·乔治狡猾手段的极致展现。他首先谈到了北爱尔兰分治的事情。爱尔兰人说，我们讨厌这样。如果你废除了它，如果你废除了贝尔法斯特议会并把阿尔斯特交给我们，也许我们会接受你们的自治领地位。
Chamberlain, the Conservative leader. Churchill said afterwards, death stood at our elbow. Yeah, because they do think the war could be on tomorrow. And what happens now is the supreme exhibition of Lloyd George's cunning. He starts off by talking about this business of partition of Northern Ireland. The Irish say, we hate it. If you scrapped it, if you scrapped the Belfast Parliament and gave us Ulster, maybe we'd accept your dominion status.
借此机会，劳合·乔治假装大发雷霆。正如巴顿所说，劳合·乔治激动起来。他在空中挥舞着文件，宣称我们是在蓄意破坏阿尔斯特，因为我们在爱尔兰的人民拒绝加入帝国。现在劳合·乔治出了他的王牌。他指着格里菲斯说：“你欺骗了我。你让我失望了。你答应过我，你会接受我的划界委员会。”
Out of that, Lloyd George pretends to have a massive temper tantrum. As Barton says, Lloyd George got excited. He shook his papers in the air, declared that we were deliberately trying to bring about a break on Ulster because our people in Ireland had refused to come within the empire. And now Lloyd George plays his card. He points at Griffith and he says, you have lied to me. You've let me down. You promised me that you would accept my boundary commission.
他掏出一张纸，这就是格里菲斯一个月前在没有仔细阅读的情况下批准的那份文件。其他的爱尔兰人都惊呆了。这是什么？这到底是怎么回事？没有人比格里菲斯本人更震惊了。他面如死灰。他彻底被这个搞懵了。现场出现了可怕的沉默。
And he pulls out this piece of paper and it's the document that Griffith had approved without properly reading it a month earlier. And the other Irishman are shocked. What's this? What's all this? And nobody is more shocked than Griffith himself. The blood drains from his features. He's completely thrown by it. There's this dreadful silence.
然后他说：“好吧，我说过我不会让你失望的，我也不会。我会签署这项条约。”他崩溃了。他就像那个在互联网上随便勾选了某个选项，却发现自己把所有钱都送给了一个俄罗斯人之类的人一样。他根本没有看小字。
And then he says, well, I said, I wouldn't let you down and I won't. I will sign the treaty. He crumbles. He's like the guy who ticks the box on something on the internet discovers that he's given away all his money to somebody in Russia or something. He hasn't read the small print. Yeah. Now as soon as he says that, Lloyd George is sort of, great, right. Well, let's move on to these other little minor things. The seas, the coast, we'll do a compromise. By the way, you can have your own tariffs. We'll
好了，他一这么说，劳合·乔治就一副——太棒了，好。那么，让我们转到这些其他的小事情上。海洋、海岸，我们会做出妥协。顺便说一句，你们可以有自己的关税。我们。
let you have that. And he says, why don't you have a new version of the oath that we all like, which Michael Collins has drafted. So now it's very complicated. This is pure Brexit negotiation, kind of arcane, hair splitting. Irish MPs will swear allegiance to the King, and I quote, in virtue of the common citizenship of Ireland with Great Britain and her adherence to and membership of the group of nations forming the British Commonwealth of Nations. So they're kind of still swearing the oath. Yeah. After this, they have a break and Lloyd George says, all right, you to make it your minds
随你便。然后他说，你们为什么不用一个我们大家都喜欢的新版誓词呢？这是迈克尔·柯林斯起草的。所以现在情况变得非常复杂。这纯粹是英国脱欧式的谈判，有点深奥晦涩，锱铢必较。爱尔兰议员将向国王宣誓效忠，我引用原文，'凭着爱尔兰与大不列颠的共同公民身份，以及她对构成大英帝国国家集团的坚持和成员身份。'所以他们实际上还在宣誓。是的。在此之后，他们休息了一下，劳合·乔治说，好吧，你们两个自己决定吧
now. He says, this is now a matter of peace or war. And by the way, I require that all of you sign. It has to be unanimous. And now the supreme bit of Lloyd George melodrama. He gets that two envelopes and he puts them on the table. And he says, this first envelope is a statement that you've accepted the terms. And he says, the other one is an announcement that the talks have failed.
现在。他说，这现在是一个和平还是战争的问题。顺便说一句，我要求你们所有人都签字。必须一致通过。现在是劳合·乔治展现巅峰情节剧时刻的时候了。他拿来两个信封，把它们放在桌子上。他说，第一个信封是一份声明，表明你们接受了这些条款。另一个信封则是宣布谈判破裂的声明。
And that means and I quote war within three days. He says, I have standing ready a special train and a destroyer to take one of these letters to Northern Ireland's prime minister, sir James Craig in Belfast, which of the two letters am I to send? I want your answer by 10 o'clock tonight. He really is a wizard, isn't he? That's great stuff. It's brilliant performative politics.
这意味着——我引用——三天内爆发战争。他说，我已经准备好了一列专列和一艘驱逐舰，把其中一封信送到北爱尔兰首相詹姆斯·克雷格爵士在贝尔法斯特的办公室。这两封信我该寄哪一封？我希望在今晚十点前得到你们的答复。他真是一个奇才，不是吗？这太棒了。这是精彩的表象政治。
You know, it's very Hollywood. George is great at it. It's like kind of pulling two rabbits out of her. Exactly. So the Irish go back to Knightsbridge and they are absolutely stunned. Gretchen Freeman describes them being in a state of profound anger, despair and panic. Griffith says, fine, I'll sign. Colin says, I'll sign.
你知道，这非常像好莱坞。乔治很擅长这个。这就像是从帽子里变出两只兔子。完全是这样。于是爱尔兰人回到骑士桥，他们彻底惊呆了。格雷琴·弗里曼形容他们处于一种深深的愤怒、绝望和恐慌状态。格里菲斯说，好吧，我签。柯林斯说，我签。
This guy, Duggan says, he'll sign. Barton says, there's no way I'm signing. Gavin Duffy says, there's no way. What about Childers? Childers is the secretary. He doesn't get a signature. He doesn't get a say, but he's sort of, he's fuming on the margins basically the whole time. He's not in favour.
这家伙达根说，他签。巴顿说，我绝不签字。加文·达菲说，绝不可能。查尔斯呢？查尔斯是秘书。他没有签字权，他没有发言权，但他基本上一直在场边怒气冲冲。他并不赞成。
He's not in favour at all. Then what follows follows there's a huge row, a massive row. Barton described it later, he said that Collins and Griffith called us murderers, they stated we'd be hanged from lamp posts, that we'd destroy all they fought for. Basically Collins and Griffith wear the other blokes down and they say fine, we'll sign it. So they go back to Downing Street. They're told they had to be back by ten but they'd been arguing so long they didn't get there till about 11. When they arrived the British actually expected that they wouldn't do it and so Griffith says fine we're all agreed we'll sign it. Lloyd George and his team are absolutely delighted. There's a bit of faffing around over the small
他一点也不赞成。接下来发生的事情是，爆发了一场巨大的争吵，一场激烈的争吵。巴顿后来描述说，柯林斯和格里菲斯称我们为杀人犯，他们说我们会吊死在路灯柱上，我们会摧毁他们为之奋斗的一切。基本上，柯林斯和格里菲斯把另几个人磨得精疲力竭，他们说好吧，我们签。于是他们回到了唐宁街。他们被告知必须在十点前回去，但他们争论了太久，直到十一点左右才到达。当他们到达时，英国人其实预计他们不会这么做，于是格里菲斯说好吧，我们都同意了，我们签字。劳合·乔治和他的团队欣喜若狂。在一些微小的细节上
print and at 10 past 2 in the morning of the 6th of December they sign the treaty. The Irish delegates go out into the fog. It's a very foggy day of course, it's the 1920s, it's London, there's bound to be loads of fog. They are silent, they're exhausted, they don't speak to the press, they just get straight into their car, all of them piling into this one car. One of them getting in the boot and they go home. And a few minutes later Lord Birkenhead and Churchill come out with these massive cigars smoking them on the steps of Downing Street. Looking like huge great capitalist imperialists.
经过一番小题大做，在12月6日凌晨2点10分，他们签署了条约。爱尔兰代表们走进迷雾中。当然这是一个大雾天，这是20世纪20年代，这里是伦敦，注定会有浓雾。他们沉默不语，精疲力竭，不跟记者说话，直接上车，所有人都挤进这一辆车里。其中一个人钻进后备箱，然后他们回家了。几分钟后，伯肯黑德勋爵和丘吉尔拿着巨大的雪茄走出来，在唐宁街的台阶上抽着雪茄。看起来就像两个伟大巨大的资本主义帝国主义者。
Exactly, and Churchill, it's Churchill of course, inevitably, who announces the deal to the world. So effectively what you have is you're going to have two entities on the island of Ireland, the two entities that are there to this day. Northern Ireland with its six counties and the other 26, which become what's then called the Irish Free State, which is a literal translation of the Irish term Seastaut Éireann, which is a term that De Valera had sometimes used himself to describe the Republic. So in other words, the British have got the deal they always wanted. And I think there were two obvious winners. One is Lloyd George,
没错，而且丘吉尔，当然是丘吉尔，不可避免地向世界宣布了这个协议。所以实际上你得到的是，在爱尔兰岛上将有两个实体，这两个实体一直存在到今天。北爱尔兰拥有其六个郡，另外26个郡成为后来被称为爱尔兰自由邦的国家，这是爱尔兰语术语Saorstát Éireann的字面翻译，这个术语是德瓦莱拉有时用来描述共和国的词。换句话说，英国人得到了他们一直想要的协议。我认为有两个显而易见的赢家。一个是劳合·乔治，
his inverted commas solved the Irish question, and he's kept his coalition in power with himself at the top. And the other big winners, of course, are the Ulster Unionists. They have their six county, two thirds Protestant majority state, which is what they wanted.
他用引号解决了爱尔兰问题，并且让他的执政联盟继续掌权，而他自己则稳坐高位。另一个大赢家，当然是阿尔斯特统一派。他们拥有了由六个郡组成、三分之二为新教徒多数的国家，这正是他们想要的。
And there were two obvious groups of losers. So one of them is Unionists and Protestants in the south of Ireland. So actually people like Sir Edward Carson, who was the original leader of the Unionists. So they find themselves now in a nationalist Catholic dominated southern Ireland, down in the Irish Free State, which is the one thing they'd always dreaded. And then the really big losers, the half a million Catholics who live in a Protestant dominated Northern Ireland. And as we will see in a future series that we'll do on the Troubles, they find themselves treated as second class citizens in everything from politics
显然也有两类明显的输家。其中之一是爱尔兰南部的统一派和新教徒。实际上就像爱德华·卡森爵士这样的人，他是统一派最初的领导人。所以他们现在发现自己身处一个由民族主义天主教徒主导的南爱尔兰，身处爱尔兰自由邦，这是他们一直最恐惧的事情。然后是真正的最大输家，生活在一个由新教徒主导的北爱尔兰的五十万天主教徒。正如我们将在未来关于北爱尔兰冲突的系列节目中所看到的，他们发现自己在从政治到
to housing, as David Trimble, the unionist leader in the 1990s said, it was a cold house for Catholics. Now in Britain, people are delighted by the treaty. Lloyd George when he briefs his cabinet, he says, I mean, this was a surprise, I think a lot of listeners to this show. He says, this is one of the greatest days in the history of the British Empire. We have fixed this problem and Ireland is still part of our family. The King sends him a telegram of congratulations, the stock market booms all his sweetness and light.
住房的方方面面都被当作二等公民对待，正如20世纪90年代的统一派领袖戴维·特林布尔所说，这对天主教徒来说是一个寒冷的家。现在在英国，人们对这项条约欣喜若狂。劳合·乔治向内阁做简报时说，我的意思是，这是一个惊喜，我想这个节目的很多听众也会这么觉得。他说，这是大英帝国历史上最伟大的日子之一。我们解决了这个问题，爱尔兰仍然是我们家庭的一部分。国王向他发来了贺电，股市繁荣，一切都是一片祥和与光明。
But in Dublin it is a very, very different story. When De Valera was told the deal had been signed, he said, what? They haven't checked with me. They're meant to have checked with me. What's going on? And someone hands in the text and he can't bring himself to read it. He is so appalled. And the problem with the deal for him and for his fellow hardliners is not the partition, I think. I mean, I think all the
但在都柏林，情况却完全不同。当德瓦莱拉被告知协议已经签署时，他说，什么？他们没有跟我核对。他们本应该跟我核对的。怎么回事？有人把文本递给他，他简直无法读下去。他是如此震惊。对于他和他的强硬派同僚来说，协议的问题不在于分区，我想。我的意思是，我想所有的
Irish historians would agree with this. They don't like partition, but they never really expected they would get the whole island. That ship had sailed. The real issue is this key issue of principle which is the oath of allegiance to the British monarch. So Michael Collins says, come on, these are just words, who cares? Doesn't matter. But to a lot of Republicans they say we're subordinate to the British monarch really
爱尔兰历史学家都会同意这一点。他们不喜欢分区，但他们从未真正期望能得到整个岛屿。那已经是过去式了。真正的问题是这个关键的原则问题，即对英国君主的效忠誓言。所以迈克尔·柯林斯说，拜托，这只是字眼，谁在乎？没关系。但对于许多共和党人来说，他们说我们真的从属于英国君主
and betraying everything that our comrades fought for the ideal of independence? Come on. So two days later the delegates get back and the Irish cabinet meets and the atmosphere is unbelievably toxic. De Valera rips into Griffith and Collins, you should never have signed this without consulting me and Griffith snaps back at him he says you didn't go to London you refused to come and this is the consequence.
并且背叛了我们的同志为之奋斗的一切——独立的理想？拜托。所以两天后代表团回来了，爱尔兰内阁开会，气氛毒化到难以置信的地步。德瓦莱拉痛斥格里菲斯和柯林斯，你们绝不应该在没有征求我意见的情况下签署这个协议，而格里菲斯回吼他说，你没有去伦敦，你拒绝来，这就是后果。
Now the thing is Griffith had broken his promise he had said he wouldn't sign and he did sign it but on the other hand I think for me I think de Valera was deranged to think that he could control the negotiations from Dublin. Or was he just playing a very very long game. So Tom by long game you mean does he think there will be a civil war he will lose it and then he will somehow get back into politics eventually? I don't think he thinks he'll lose it. I think maybe he thinks that the negotiations will happen.
问题是，格里菲斯打破了他的承诺，他说过他不会签，但他还是签了；但另一方面，在我看来，德瓦莱拉认为他能从都柏林控制谈判，简直是疯了。还是说他只是在下一盘非常非常大的棋？汤姆，你说的下大棋是指他认为会爆发内战，他会输掉内战，然后他会不知怎么地最终重新回到政坛吗？我不认为他认为自己会输。我想也许他认为谈判会发生。
He will stand on the right side of history. The negotiators will fail. The British will have signed the treaty and so they won't have any appetite for war and he can just step in and be the hero. Yeah, I think he does think that. I think he thinks he will ride in at the end as the hero of the hour and he has been denied that opportunity because they have signed this treaty. There'll be some listeners who are more sympathetic to De Valera who say he was betrayed by his
他会站在历史正确的一边。谈判代表会失败。英国人已经签署了条约，所以他们不会对战争有任何胃口，他就可以直接介入并成为英雄。是的，我想他是这么想的。我想他认为他会在最后作为时代英雄骑马登场，而由于他们签署了这份条约，他的这个机会被剥夺了。有些听众会更同情德瓦莱拉，认为他被他的
negotiators or whatever. Ronan Fanning, who's his biographer, accuses him of a gross evasion of the responsibilities of leadership. And I think, I mean, obvious difference between Lloyd George and De Valera is Lloyd George takes personal control of the negotiations. They are his baby from start to finish. He runs them masterfully. De Valera washes his hands of them and refuses to get involved. And if you're a leader, you have to get involved, I would say. But just to stick up for De Valera, I mean, had the negotiations been happening in Dublin, then he might have turned up. Maybe.
谈判代表出卖了，诸如此类。罗南·范宁，他的传记作家，指责他极其逃避领导责任。我的意思是，劳合·乔治和德瓦莱拉之间明显的区别在于，劳合·乔治亲自掌控了谈判。从头到尾这就是他的心血结晶。他极其熟练地掌控了谈判。而德瓦莱拉则甩手不管，拒绝参与其中。如果你是一个领袖，你必须参与其中，我会这么说。但为了给德瓦莱拉说句公道话，我的意思是，如果谈判是在都柏林进行的，那么他可能会露面。也许吧。
There is no parallel universe by the way in which those negotiations happen in Dublin. I know. Anyway, by the end of that day, Irish politics is already irretrievably divided. The cabinet voted by four to three, the Irish cabinet to back the deal and de Valera was furious and he issued a statement straight away. He said the deal is in violent conflict with the wishes of the majority of this nation which is not actually as it turns out true. There's then an incredibly bitter debate in the Doyle which dragged on into January. On the one hand you have the anti-treaty people who say you've betrayed the ideal of the republic you betrayed all our friends
顺便说一句，绝对没有平行宇宙能让那些谈判在都柏林进行。我知道。无论如何，到那天结束时，爱尔兰政坛已经四分五裂，无法挽回。爱尔兰内阁以四比三的投票结果支持这项协议，德瓦莱拉大发雷霆，并立即发表了一份声明。他说，该协议与这个国家大多数人的愿望存在剧烈冲突，而事实证明这其实并非事实。随后，爱尔兰议会进行了极其痛苦的辩论，一直拖到一月。一方面，有反条约派的人说你们背叛了共和国的理想，背叛了我们所有
who died and on the other hand you have most famously Collins. Collins really puts himself on the line defending this. He says this is the best deal we could get, we're never going to win a war against the British, we've made the biggest step towards independence in Ireland's history and he says it doesn't give us everything we want but, famous quotation, it gives us the freedom to achieve it. The Doyle voted on the 7th of January and they voted by 64 votes to 57 to back the treaty. De Valera led his supporters out of the chamber the next day and Collins shouts at them as they go out and he calls them deserters and his parting shot as De Valera and Erskine Childers go out of the chamber he goes for the worst insult in the Irish
战死的朋友，另一方面，有最著名的柯林斯。柯林斯真正挺身而出捍卫这一点。他说这是我们能得到的最好的协议，我们永远不会赢得对英国的战争，我们已经迈出了爱尔兰历史上走向独立的最大一步，他说这并没有给我们想要的一切，但用那句名言来说，它给了我们实现这一目标的自由。议会在1月7日进行了投票，以64票对57票通过了该条约。第二天，德瓦莱拉带领他的支持者走出会场，柯林斯在他们离开时对他们大喊大叫，称他们为逃兵，当德瓦莱拉和厄斯金·查尔斯离开会场时，他给出了爱尔兰
political lexicon. He says, foreigners, Americans, English. Because De Valera had been born in America and Childers of course was English. Yeah. So in the next few weeks, the Republican movement tears itself apart. Even the IRA splits into competing factions. And on the 14th of April 1922, about 150 armed IRA fighters, anti-treaty faction, occupy one of the biggest buildings in Dublin, which is the Four Courts Legal Complex. And they're doing this as a deliberate provocation to
政治词典中最恶毒的侮辱。他说，外国人、美国人、英国人。因为德瓦莱拉出生在美洲，而查尔斯当然是英国人。是的。所以在接下来的几周里，共和党运动四分五裂。甚至爱尔兰共和军也分裂成相互竞争的派系。1922年4月14日，大约150名武装的爱尔兰共和军战士，即反条约派系，占领了都柏林最大的建筑之一，即四法院法律综合大楼。他们这样做是为了对
the new pro-treaty government of Griffith and Collins, and indeed to the British. For the next few weeks, they are still there in this building and everybody is waiting and the tension is rising. And then on the 22nd of June, news arrives from London of an assassination on the streets of London in broad daylight that shocks the world and will change everything. Brilliant, Dominic. Thanks ever so much. So we will continue this story on Monday when we will be returning to Dublin and we'll be exploring the outbreak of the Irish Civil War in the very place where it begins in the
格里菲斯和柯林斯的新亲条约政府，以及对英国进行蓄意挑衅。在接下来的几周里，他们依然留在这个建筑里，每个人都在等待，紧张局势不断升级。然后，在6月22日，伦敦传来了消息，伦敦街头发生了一起白日谋杀案，震惊了世界，并将改变一切。太精彩了，多米尼克。非常感谢。所以我们将在周一继续这个故事，届时我们将重返都柏林，并将在爱尔兰内战爆发的地点探寻其起因，就在
heart of the Irish capital in the Four Courts complex and we will be joined there by the brilliant Ronan Mcreevey and if you want to get both those episodes on Monday then you can do so by joining our very own elite negotiating team the Restless History Club at therestlesshistory.com. Thank you Dominic, thank you everyone for listening. Bye bye. Bye bye. listen to the adverts on these episodes and you sometimes think, do you know what? I wish that the listeners to this podcast, I wish they were listening to an advert about my brand rather than the other stuff that Tom and Dominic are promoting on here. If you have thought that, there is of course only one way to find out what that would be like.
爱尔兰首都中心的四法院大楼，届时出色的罗南·麦克里维将与我们一同前往。如果你想在周一收听这两集节目，可以通过加入我们自己的精英谈判团队——'无畏历史俱乐部'来做到这一点，网址是therestlesshistory.com。谢谢你，多米尼克，谢谢大家的收听。再见。再见。听这些剧集里的广告，有时你会想，你知道吗？我希望这个播客的听众听的是关于我品牌的广告，而不是汤姆和多米尼克在这里推广的其他东西。如果你有过这种想法，当然只有一个方法可以知道那会是什么感觉。
You can disrupt the procession of adverts. You could be the next HSBC premiere or the many other tremendous companies that have advertised on the rest is history. And you could put your brand in front of millions of like-minded listeners by advertising on the rest is history and indeed the other shows on the Goalhanger Network. Now you may be thinking, I don't know what the Goalhanger Network is. Goalhanger are the company behind this very show. And if you are in the market to increase the value of your brand, Goalhanger would love to hear from you.
你可以打断广告的进程。你可以成为下一个汇丰银行尊贵理财客户，或是曾在'历史沉思录'上做过广告的众多卓越公司之一。通过在'历史沉思录'以及高挂网络（Goalhanger Network）的其他节目上投放广告，你可以将你的品牌展现在数百万志同道合的听众面前。现在你可能会想，我不知道什么是高挂网络。高挂公司正是这个节目的幕后公司。如果你正盘算着提升你品牌的价值，高挂公司将非常乐意听到你的声音。
You can register your interest or indeed your company's interest by going to goalhanger.com right now. And that is goal, G-O-A-L, hangar, H-A-N-G-E-R, dot com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你现在就可以前往 goalhanger.com 表达你的兴趣，或者表达你公司的兴趣。也就是 goal，G-O-A-L，hangar，H-A-N-G-E-R，点 com。本集节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。